the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
the final day of Rapid was filled with
decisive results at the superbed rapid
and Blitz in Warsaw Poland with crucial
points up for grass tail Ender scrambled
to gain ground as Front Runners pressed
on the King has returned and the field
took notice as world number one Magnus
Carlson took the Romanian players to
task winning his first two games of this
event Levon aronian cruise by co-leader
Wesley so but was unable to steal the
lead from John kierstock Duda drawing
their final round match-up Duda remains
hot and sits in Seoul lead after the
rapid section and he Blitz his way to a
second title day four of thrilling chess
coming up next
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back everybody to day four of
the 2023 Superbad rapid and Blitz held
here in Warsaw Poland we've had some
exciting Fighting Chess in the rapid
portion but finally the action is about
to get faster and more Furious because
the blitz is beginning is going to be
super exciting let's go to the studio
and start today's games
we welcome you to the second stop on the
2023 crunches tour and our coverage of
Superbad Poland we come to you live from
the San Luis chess club
good morning and welcome everyone thank
you for joining us I'm International
Master Nazi Pai kids and I'm here with
Grandmaster yes everyone Nasi has been
great I really enjoyed it what do you
think about Duda he's undefeated and
just cruising yes indeed hello everyone
thank you for joining us and Welcome to
our show as the super bet moves to the
blitz stage and from Nasi and myself we
have just three words to say about the
rapid
fabulous it's great and let's take a
look at the standings Nasi
right after round nine we have so little
young Kristoff doodle the 13 points and
closely following livon aronian one
point and sharing third Wesley so and
Maxi Michelle Agra also one for you and
the world number one came back yesterday
and in clear Steve's place right now
Magnus Carlson welcome back Magnus we
missed you and Richard report in clear
six uh then sharing Seventh Place rather
slavoy tashek and Anish giri and back
then Daniel the AC was six points and
Carol shevchenko with four points and
tell us about the format it's Blitz baby
then playing around Robin and the time
control is five minutes with two second
increments traditional scoring system
1.4 win half fourth row and zero for
loss no draw offers and tell us about
the schedule we have two days of Blitz
coming up and today we have rounds one
through nine and tomorrow will be the
final day rounds 10 to 18th outstanding
and very fortunate to have in studio
varusian VAR uh we've got five players
in form and they are some of the
greatest Blitz players in the world what
are you looking at yeah I'm very excited
to see how the blitz portion will go and
these players are Specialists and I
think they all have chances here even
Magnus with these three points behind
but I think if he has a really hot
streak here he has a chance to catch up
with Duda let's take a look at the live
rankings in blitz so we're Magnus third
in the world and ish fifth Levon sixth
uh ninth and then we have Wesley as well
these five players are really strong
Specialists and of course let's not
forget mvl who won the world Blitz
Championship two years ago in Poland and
of course Richie report always very
dangerous
and let's take a look at dudas line
score here he's been very very
impressive undefeated with four wins and
five draws clear first place but closely
followed by Lebon so still many many
games to go 18 rounds of Blitz so
anything can happen
and we can go to Poland to our
colleagues Anastasia and Christian
thanks Warren welcome back chess fans to
day four here in Warsaw Poland for the
super bet rapid and Blitz and what an
exciting event we've had so far but the
action is about to get faster and of
course more furious and I have my eyes
on two incredible players one of them is
Levon aronian let's not forget he is in
fact the Wild Card going into uh this
event after the world champion ding
dropped out of the event and he was told
that he's going to play this event only
a week ago he didn't have enough time to
get any opening preparation going but he
is an instinctive genius and he's
showing it in this event so far he's
been doing amazing but I have to say I
talked to him after the last round
yesterday and he was a bit disappointed
that he was unable to overcome the
tenacious defense of Duda with that
Victory he would have leapfrogged Duda
and he would have been the sole leader
going into the blitz portion
nevertheless still plenty of games to go
still plenty of chances to potentially
put his stamp on this event and of
course another player that I'm having my
eyes on is the former world champion
Magnus Carlson who is definitely warming
up in day three he had a great day at
the office two victories with the black
pieces and that incredible game against
Richie Rapport in the final round he's
definitely enjoying playing a chess and
it definitely shows in the event so far
Anastasia you've been hanging around
with Magnus you've been following him
along what did you see from him yeah
I've saw him many times given autographs
you know all the time you know even when
he is walking to the to the plane when
you some people jump on him and try to
get some selfies and autographs and it's
really nice to see him in a good mood
and of course today is a special day for
him too because his coach his second
bitter honey Nielsen has 50th
Anniversary his birthday and Magnus
seven published tweet a great birthday
to him happy birthday Peter and maybe if
the day goes well he will also devote
some of the victories to his coach well
we have had some great ones and many
more to come he is predicting so
definitely and take a look at this I
mean craziness is crazy I mean you can't
imagine how many people were waiting for
Magnus yesterday he spent I don't know
15 minutes to half an hour signing
autographs taking selfies it was really
nice of him actually to you know really
to please the crowd and everybody was
happy kids were you know so happy
smiling and they caught some videos
during this time you see the kids
it was really nice and but I also keep
my eyes on young Christoph today you
know he is my team of course by the way
last year he won this event and as they
say even walls help you right I mean
he's a local here he feels really good
here also many fans are after him and
like people are watching him here and
he's a local star so I really think that
it's going to be an interesting fight
today between those great players the
energy is absolutely amazing here in
Warsaw we will be giving you all at the
insights analyze some games and keep you
guys up to date with what's happening
here see you guys soon social media
social media don't forget about social
media never never forget about social
media please follow all our accounts
Grant Your Story with for some insights
and more videos thank you Anastasia
thank you Christian a very heartwarming
to see those photos of uh Magnus uh
signing all of this automated fans yes
uh but Nancy set the table for us tell
us about the pairings for the Blitz
round one let's take a look we have diak
playing shevchenko boy tashek against
Wesley saw Magnus Carlson playing mvl
and that will be our Marquee matchup
that will concentrate it on for this
game against Duda and that will be Plan
B here against aronia very very nice and
they were expecting a lot of Fighting
Chess what are they fighting for they
are fighting for a handsome price fund
their first place winner is going to get
forty thousand dollars second place
thirty thousand third place twenty five
thousand hundred and seventy five
thousand dollars in total prizes all the
way down to 10th Place seven thousand
dollars the grand Chester points out for
grabs win clear first you get a bonus
point of 13 points tied for first you
chop up the 12 points the player with
the most grand chess tour points at the
end of the tour gets a sveld extra one
hundred thousand dollar bonus it's it's
all the play for is there you see our
leader with the black pieces uh
when you're playing Blitz by the way I
always like to wear a suit jackets or
the tie and stuff what are you playing
Blitz
[Applause]
Carlson I remember tournament played in
Amsterdam where it was the professors
versus the youths and Magnus was playing
we all went on a canal boat trip and uh
Magnus was leaning over the boat
back in by the hips and said don't tempt
me to throw you overboard as you see
Gary
yeah he doesn't know where he wants to
move
to play
oh he Wesley was saying go ahead
oh
yes because Michael
there he is just waiting
[Music]
in the move or to make the move
yes
and the round begins and the round
begins once again because
there's five games and they'll be
playing so fast we'll focus on one if it
pizzles out we'll move but the game
we're going to focus on is Magnus versus
mvl knight F3 inviting an open Sicilian
will Magnus bike before it's not I feel
like he's in a rush he's not in a rush
C4 four okay so will we be seeing
a
E5 yes e5's on the board very very
popular
system I love playing this as white
myself I've
a castle play a2a3 go for the B4 break
and try to sit on the D5 Square that's
been my go-to plan forever and ever rmn
there's still a lot of theory here
absolutely
and black knight usually goes to E7
correct yes yes the it's a little bit
more flexible allows black on occasion
to play for F7 F5 there we have it a283
now the conventional story is you go
Rook B1 91 you go Rook B1
Knight E1
Knight to C2 and Knight goes to E3 it's
it's a long wind maneuver but the idea
is you want to park your night on the
beautiful Outpost D5 in the middle of
the board here we go Rook B1 once Knight
is on C2 this white also maybe want to
play B4 oh absolutely absolutely Bishop
G5
it rather induces the move F7 F6 if you
do play H6 I am willing to capture the
Knight now this I think is a mistake or
a mistine by black because uh now it's
easier for white to take command of the
D5 Square uh if you're this bishop on G7
doesn't fight for and just to mention
black splan they usually also play at
five and try to expand on the king side
while white plays in the center and
possibly on the queen side with B4
exactly so here it comes uh Knight D5
is an automatic with the idea of
following it up very very quickly let me
get rid of my arrows Knight to D5
attacking the queen normally speaking
you don't want to trade with Knight D5
with the idea of B4 and we here we go
now will we see B4 bar
um I'm thinking it's comfy for white but
maybe the computer has a different idea
no you're absolutely right it's a very
big Advantage now for white it's a very
easy to play exactly b-file is going to
get opened and I think that move F6 was
necessary when the bishop was on G5 to
try to prevent Bishop takes E7 because
now it's it's very very easy to play the
Knight on D5 is very strong clear the
plant pressure on B7 especially in Blitz
this is a dream position for white
agreed a great opening Choice by Magnus
yeah well it certainly is playing out by
the way Pawn on C5 is very vulnerable if
it was my turn I could take and play
Knight B3 and you just tell me how
you're going to defend C5
you're looking yolking looking it's not
easy messy I mean so already and we
could see for example after takes Knight
takes B4 uh the bishop on on G2
eyeballing this long diagonal
it's not easy Maxim needs to maybe
sacrifice a pond somewhere to try to
create the counter play on the king side
so maybe take on B4 and E4 or something
real really quickly yes just to break
break up White's uh strategy which
really rather plays itself again white
is looking to capture on C5 to maybe
play with B5 maybe play Knight B3 and
just go for the queen side in the
meantime
with black pardon me with White's King
only protected by the bishop you got to
do something but F4 nah you just give up
I like E4 followed by these ideas of
maybe even
G5 with the idea E4 and F4 but yeah and
by the way clock times clock times they
maximum
so he has two minutes
seconds and Magnus has uh three minutes
and 40 seconds a significant uh
difference on the clock uh definitely in
Blitz time matters a lot so I really
don't like yeah I mean I agree that you
didn't want a weakness on C5
yeah this whole strategy of Rook C8 that
the rook's not well placed here first of
all there is that and secondly that just
you know pulls your Pieces away from
your whole E4 so here A Move Like E3 I I
find very flexible I love B6 looks very
good in in terms of basketball terms
posting up uh very nice and here we go
Mexican playing H5 trying to create some
counter play on the king side again it
will not be easy yeah but I don't like
this move because it invites the answer
Knight F3 threatening Knight G5 you're
virtually forced to play Bishop H6 I
think Magnus should play H4 now or is it
unnecessary I'm thinking I just want to
defend D5 so I probably will start with
the move I don't want to see Bishop
takes and the diagonal being closed so
I'm thinking Rook to B5
possibly Knight E1 Knight B3 and Knight
Knight C2 and night before but I'm
thinking Rook uh
E5 for the moment there is a very nice
tactic there yesterday if you play H4
yes it's a very good move actually to
control the G5 and if you take on D5
yeah Knight takes E5
wheat so H4 and guess what he spotted
the tactic Bishop takes D5 Knight takes
E5 followed by Bishop takes D5 and
maximum How Sweet It Is it avoided it
and now we have Rook B5
uh he's playing all of our moves these
guys are good we keep emphasizing it I I
didn't really see the difference between
playing H4 I thought Rook B5 and you can
always play H4 black would probably
immediately go G5
so Magnus just wants to shut it down
completely
oh sure G5 H4 G5 G4 Knight G5 uh I again
I love this PO what is white doing white
is ready to go Rook B5 Queen B3 I mean
triple and force uh oh it's just not
going well for for how should uh White
deal with this D5 issue right now you
take on E7 we take because we don't have
Knight B6 option
yeah I I I I I feel like every time I
trade off a defender of the D5 Square
this bishop will not be able to defend
the D5 Square so I feel I'm getting get
it I was going to say I like trading and
then following it up with Queen B3 and
keeping the diagonal open
not that white two things that once
defend in D5 and prepare in Rook B1 yeah
but at the same time this bishop on G2
is a little bit crying okay I get it you
can play now Knight D2 and Knight C4
nice score for the Knight attacking D6
gorgeous Square for the night seriously
VAR this feels like play on one goal and
where is Maxine there's no counter
playing Maxim is in big trouble I think
this is just a losing position Knight is
going to come to Sephora as you
mentioned the other Rook will come to B1
and eventually I think one of the spawns
will fall on B7 or D6 here it's
extremely passive position and even the
move F4 that you're gonna try to do you
have to be very careful because
sometimes that will allow the move
Bishop H3 Bishop E6 later on as well and
that would be devastating if the bishop
gets only six so very very passive
position and according to engines this
is just winning for white yeah Knight D2
easy play bit surprising uh that that
Magnus is thinking the only reason I can
imagine him thinking is he's
contemplating
playing D4 or even possibly playing E4
for the reasons E4 is very strong here
E4 possibly for the reasons you were
just mentioning Bishop H3 but he he
falls back on
I mean I would find this move so
compelling the Knight looks I mean just
compare Knights I mean you know the
knights speak for themselves
and Maxim has minute and five seconds
now Madness one minute and 20 seconds I
love what VAR was saying E4 Bishop H3
bringing that Bishop into the into the
uh play uh Bishop he starts with Bishop
H3 love it before we'll be coming love
it always look
pardon me always look at your pieces and
say how can I improve them Bishop on G2
defends the king is very nice but the
king is not under attack and whereas you
put the bishop on H3 you follow it up
with E4 and your Bishop is immediately
put to work if you wanted to play Rook
B1 you've got my my vote there is a
slight possibility that the move F2 F4
could be compelling and that's why I
don't think Magnus wanted to commit
himself
I think the key point is after we play
E4 if we manage to open up this diagonal
but he just played E4 yeah we would be
taking the Knight on C8 and then D6 and
B7 would just fall absolutely absolutely
and here it looks like D6 is under a lot
of pressure right Rook B6 next if needed
rugby six nights yeah right but uh this
move just cozying up to the B Pawn
really asks a very Salient question what
are you going to do and well there
wasn't much for mvl to do he's holding
he's holding VAR how do you breach
Black's defenses do you play for Queen
B2 and F4 do you play to create a
weakness on PlayStore K5 very good oh
breaking through on the a file maybe
yeah now Rook B1 will come as well and
and by the way guys Duda is about to
lose his first game and that will be a
big result if Magnus wins now it'll be
only two points difference between him
and do that commentators curse
Wesley drew his game against voytashek
okay and by the way uh Magnus has made
some very very serious inroads I
mentioned a moment ago that The Rook
um has uses on F1 suddenly yes keep one
piece near the king to defend everything
on the king side and looks like White's
Queen at night will just pick up
everything on the queen side it it sure
does and there goes that D6 Pawn we
spoke about it and Magnus is like what's
better than being one Pawn up being up
two Pawn there you go
uh F4 and this is a basically a Hail
Mary I mean nine seconds and to remind
everyone they only have two second
increments exactly
takes takes
there goes uh the queen trade we have
officer card Bishops but two extra pawns
extra points and we have other pieces on
the board exactly now here Rook F7
even better
Magnus is playing technique is just
incredible superb he really is playing a
superb game at the moment so now just
Rook F7 looks very tempting right oh
definitely Rook F7 with the ID in 98
Knight E6 now you can play
MBL five seconds yeah
but Madness 15 seconds
you gotta like the spike check
yeah I think we're a few moves away from
resigning right yeah we're just making
sure there's no perpetuals but yeah uh
sorry but great game but I really want
to say very very one-sided I think we've
got
Duda Richie oh Rapport is completely
three pounds ahead what's better than
being two pawns ahead and there we go we
just came in at the very end it looks
like punishes winning against Lebon guys
Anish Gary
oh Blitz what's happening well we did
um when we opened the show VAR was
showing us the highest rated players in
the world in Blitz a niche is one of
them yes and there you see the little
petite combination that anisha's just
set up Bishop takes G5 you can't capture
because and Rook G5 and game over oh
wait I think he blundered
wow it was Rook takes H6
Rook takes H6
oh never mind check
is time a factor I see very nervous
looking on his Gary
they're both playing on five seconds so
oh wow of course Anish is winning but
anything can happen although a pawn
pushes itself uh-huh
it's key it's going on deep it's going
it's going it's not gone but it's it's
coronation Time Queen David eight
attacked the bishop
white now has two connected passers C
and D yeah but there's some counter play
with the beep maybe two seconds
oh well you're right here we go
here we go yeah those two pawns are
unstoppable true that and The Bishop's a
little bit trapped as well
yeah that's a very strong measure he's
trapped now so the pawns are going to
cost uh
so two leaders today Duda and livon boss
lost right out of their first loss for
both of them wow and also
Maggie that was like very nice sorry and
kitty I think that's his first win in
the tournament as well oh
congratulations yeah one so we had four
decisive results out of five we had a
bad start wow
um
I'm still kind of impre well I am over
overly impressed by Maggie there I mean
mvl just he he was watching he was
watching throughout bar what caught your
eye absolutely the Magnus game was very
very impressive and again he's he's
picking up a form here the game that
caught my ad was Richard report winning
against Duda the leader of the
tournament and giving Duda his first
loss here I want to show you the opening
because a very unusual opening and which
is expected from a report here so D4
Knight F6 Bishop G5 and I played the
move C5 and here we know D5 is one of
the main moves in this position but he
just took on F6 and now he took on C5
this is a little bit unusual because
normally we play the move D5 here but
looks like Richie knew what to do and
got a really good position out of the
opening Here and Now simply developing
his pieces and he went for the long cast
link here and uh Queen D4 centralizing
the queen getting ready to play long
castle and uh
and right out of the opening I think he
had a very comfortable position because
it was difficult for black to figure out
what to do with the skin care you can't
really Castle short and also it was
difficult to cast along for him as well
and Richie continue with this Knight G3
I like this idea because now the Knight
on G3 is threatening to play Knight H5
very annoying putting pressure on F6 so
he forced him with H5 but now we know
that this is going to be a problem and
after the move H4 is just going to be a
weakness and bishopy too so and he got a
very nice position here here already
white has a very very nice advantage and
uh it looks like it came from
yes exactly it doesn't matter yeah and
now D5 came in and he captured again
throughout the whole game he had a very
nice Advantage here and he's already up
a pawn here and picked up a second Bond
and eventually converted into a victory
here and the other game that I have here
guys is the voitashics so this was more
or less a very solid game here and not
that much happened here Queen's Gambit
declined and players played a very solid
line and
it end up in an end game
and I've actually played this before
it's just a very very solid position you
know symmetrical time pound structure as
well and uh after a lot of exchanges it
just fizzled out into a draw
thank you Vari and you were mentioning
four decisive games now see tell us
about the standings and how those four
games shook them up
so right so yeah both UDA and Lavon lost
so their their score didn't change but
Wesley made a draw so he got a half a
point and Magnus Carlson won so he's now
with MBL and yes exactly and Richard won
his game uh he's still in the sixth
place but 10 points very close to
sharing fourth as well my pick Anish is
in there with a shout uh yes he
delivered a nice win and radoslav Drew
against Wesley right right and baghdan
had a loss against kiril and finally
Carol uh winning our first game well
done to him and let's jump to Warsaw for
the view there Christian and Anastasia
fireworks in all the games guys I have
to tell you and let's pick it up where
we left it we didn't see uh we saw only
the end of this game Anish versus Levon
and what a critical game Anish hasn't
had a very good event so far Levon is
been uh playing great chess but
unfortunately for him not in this game
let's take a look at what happened Anish
opened with the Italian Joko piano you
know inviting a long game and this is
exactly what he got as we can see and he
also knew the theory better as I will
show you in just a second Bishop to A4
C6 and now B5 this is the novelty uh
coming from Levon but unfortunately is
not a great novelty better would have
been to go Knight H5 try to secure uh
control over that F4 square and
potentially
um hang around with the Knights uh F4
maybe Knight to H4 this would have given
black a great position B5 the problem is
I can hook that with a move A4 and
that's going to create some structural
weaknesses in the position and giri I
have to say he exploited them quite well
i2f1 Knight to G3 now C5 due to this
reason white has a great opportunity to
close the center which he did with the
move D5 follow it up with C4 do not
allow black to go C4 because now the
bishop Pawn A7 doesn't have where to go
is going to be locked forever and take a
look this is play on one goal as yassero
always likes likes to say Rook to G1
Knight wish to very important move to
try to go F4 and open up the position on
the king side and he played the model
game the problem is he got himself in
trouble as we will see Anish that is and
you guys caught the moment
um on camera right there it was at this
point he was playing a brilliant game
nice attacking game everything is
Flowing correctly and this was the
critical move wow Bishop takes G5 Rook
F7 and now Bishop takes H6 blunder alert
Rook takes H6 good start and after Rook
to G5 this was the critical mistake of
course it's very difficult to find and
at this point I think he only had a few
seconds left Rook to F1 wins for black
Levon aronian had a golden opportunity
King G2 and now Rook to F4 forcing Rook
takes G6 because you have to do
something this queen and that's a pin oh
my God you can go back to G3 but now I
take on G5 and now that that's another
pin Rook to G6 so you don't have time uh
to get your right position with the king
and the Queen off the G file this would
have been a golden opportunity for Levon
he did not take that and after that he
lost an easy game Anastasia which game
were you I was looking at the game in
this terrible between two Romanian
players Bogdan deck and uh but before
that I want to say that Gary Kasparov
came to make this first symbolic move
for Magnus and his place was empty and
Wesley so immediately invited Gary to
play you know instead of Magnus and they
were laughing a lot about it but Denmark
just jumped in then okay he had to make
this
yes yes you can play a couple of moves
but not more so kiril shipchenko
actually
managed to win this game but it was
still a very interesting there were a
few interesting moments so let's first
he was not having such a great
tournament so far but there were a
couple of interesting moments so they
went uh to this position over here is it
is it all fine in
so 83 yes yes it's three and uh I mean
okay they were you know playing with uh
with knights maneuvering and then this
movie four I think was not so great
because he gave up the square on D4 so
black came finally was the Knight on D4
and here was also very interesting
moment Bishop could take on day five and
there was some crazy variation from the
composer like you go here and then crazy
move Knight B3 and if you take all this
look what happens at the end of the
variation like all the pieces are
getting lost and then Bishop C4 so it
was a very interesting opportunity I
honestly think he just forgot about that
A5 Pawn yes I think so but but I think
they were calculating all these
variations and in the end decided maybe
not to go for it so he played Just solid
Rook B1 but you can understand that
black is now better after that yeah so I
want to show also another one so black
was was good all the way but look what
happened at certain point I mean I just
want to get here Rook F6 and then rook
d8 and here white could sorry if we go
back to Rook G6 yes
so that was very very nice moment which
I want to to show yes instead of taking
on D6 white could have taken on F7 and
The Logical move Rook D2 right I mean
you want to play this movie it looks
like it's winning yes but it's really
cool why it looks too Rook takes and
then Rook f8 you can find the Checkmate
yes in couple of moves or maybe yes yes
G7 Rook F7 let's show it on the board
this is how white could actually finish
the game instead of it uh Bogdan took on
D6 exchanged the Rooks and unfortunately
uh after that black just have really
great position you know this bishop on
G2 is doing nothing and they eventually
curio one and probably on time yeah
actually did not manage to make this
move Rook takes D6 on time so I was
probably calculating Rook takes F7 he
did not play it he went for Rook 66 but
too late he lost some time wow this is
this will happen Okay we didn't have
chance to run there but now we
understood this is the highway variants
that Magnus has been talking about in
The Blitz portion and right now Magnus
by the way he's only two points behind
Duda this tournament is hitting up guys
through the magic of Television let's
just review a moment there between Anish
Gary and Lavon aronian at the very end
as the two pawns just going up the board
cruising and this move I really like
dominates the bishop Queen A5 trapping
the queen in the midst of all this
exactly and and Lavon
realizing
yeah nothing to be done and uh very nice
Anish and as we get ready for our round
two uh let's take a look at our
standings right the Anchorage of Judah
is still in solid right despite a loss
his first loss of the event yes close
the following level neronium in the
second place and clear third Wesley so
and Sharon fourth Magnus Crossing thanks
to magnus's victory over MBA over MBO
right uh Sharon with MPL Richie climbing
up a little bit and then the sixth place
and Anish giri was a win also trying to
catch up with the litters make me proud
a niche
and let's just take a look at our
rounded two Blitz pairings coming up as
you do that
so Levon has second black pieces today
right uh do that again scary
by Sheila gravigan's report
and Wesley so against Carl fun that's
got to be our Marquee uh game but we'll
we will use the Duda Gary as a backup
yes and we have diak against
the the blitz is hot and Furious uh Nasi
and I are just kind of catching our
breaths uh what about you mark same very
exciting can we see both leaders uh Duda
and Levon losing and that opens up the
tournament even more now I think Magnus
is in the race now which is only two
points and still 18 Blitz Games to go so
it's very hard to see who who is going
to win somebody needs to have a really
good streak in this blitz portion to
have a good chance to win this
tournament so very excited to see what's
gonna happen in next few rounds guys
yeah well thank you for that absolutely
and once again this is our schedule
right we have two days of Blitz and
today they're playing rounds one through
nine right tomorrow will be the final
day and they will play 10th through 18th
games exactly so it's double round robin
so when you were telling him that was it
Leman has two blacks yes he'll start
tomorrow with the two whites because
they'll just reverse the the colors but
okay
four out of five games decisive eighty
percent so that variance Factor once you
once the uh clocks are sped up
considerably you do see the players
having far more decisive games less
trust and that's why we love Blitz
exactly we sure do
and we don't have anybody undefeated
anymore we had Levon Levon and uh do
that and they both lost so no undefeated
players anymore so now I think player is
going to take more chances I don't know
I wanna I wanna argue that um
Magnus is undefeated he only lost his
first game ever since that first loss
which you can forget about yeah
that's a warm-up game it was a warm
again it was a practice we have a poll
uh that we asked oh oh we're not ready
quite ready to share what the poll was
about but uh we might have asked
I'll ask our panel going into tomorrow's
round will there be a clear leader
we had a clear leader coming into today
uh you think so yes but there will be a
few people who'll be very close very
close jump in yeah I think so I think
there will be a clear leader and uh I'm
gonna take a bold prediction I think
Magnus will be the leading the
tournament but they'll be very close ooh
I on the other hand will play the
contrarian uh players have a tendency to
somehow gather right uh birds of a
feather flock together type of thing I'm
going to suggest that there's going to
be a three-way tie for first and here is
the poll
so which of this video Blitz radio
players will perform best today that's
the question and 68 of people said
Magnus Carlsen right 16 young Crystal
and only seven percent people said live
on Anish well it must be the Jedi mind
trick out there I've got I've convinced
people that my my pick for the
tournament wasn't so bad I mean it's a
terrible thing at least as far as the
wrap that's working also he is very high
rated in Blitz yes he's number five in
the world yeah he's really really up
there as the players getting ready uh
for uh the second game round again
Wesley so quietly at the top as well VAR
uh Wesley Magnus in terms of Blitz do we
have those stats how they do head to
head with one another
we don't keep the stance of the uh of
the the blitz but I have to I'm thinking
that Wesley is not only a seasoned Blitz
player but I think he's very successful
uh in the Blitz and Rapids Barb
absolutely absolutely agree Wesley is a
very natural player and he's just his
instincts are great again he doesn't
make too many mistakes and he's got
fantastic time management I personally
played him hundreds of Blitz Games he's
just one of the very very top Blitz
players in the world wow is he's getting
into the Zone preparing the face uh
Magnus Carlson yes or do you think we'll
have a single match today where it will
be five draws no
yeah I I think so many players here are
swinging for the fences I think they
love the fact that you know they don't
really care about their Blitz ratings
yeah they do but they really don't not
as much as their classical the classical
ratings are really what's going to get
them their invites so when you know the
gloves are off and you can just throw
the patties I mean look at these two
guys like would a loss ruin their
careers no you know just their mood and
their day exactly just their mood in the
day very very temporary thing and so you
guys don't get to take a lot of risks
usually in their classical games to help
yeah the blitz is where they all do it
exactly now the youthful Carol versus
the Wily old Fox I think I can call him
that you will you'll hate me for love me
for it Lavon saying okay young man you
know let me take you to the school and
show you how we do it
this is getting scanned
I like the report from Anastasia on the
social media the other day that Magnus
wasn't recognized and he couldn't clear
through security
he wasn't wearing the the
his his standard pickup line hi I'm
Magnus Carlson didn't work I mean
right
oh that's our official photographer and
uh yeah we have a ceremonial first move
so
if you want it e2e4
I'm not sure if that was a super bad I'm
not sure what that was yes yeah we
didn't get the name we didn't get the
name
no worries as Wesley so and the round
begins and Magnus Carlson starting round
two oh Scandinavian was not expecting
that okay
so we have has Magnus played
Scandinavian recently I've seen him play
it in Blitz
but uh yeah it's it's a rarity on the
top but when you want to surprise your
opponent it's one of those things that
when you're not completely ready like
Wesley is so ready for E4 E5 uh Berlin
or
uh Italian when you're not completely
ready to to meet a Scandinavian it can
be a little bit awkward Bishop B4 okay
not C7 C6
do you think Wesley remembers the
theories I do I I just think that you
check everything all the time he's so
incredibly well prepared and just the
fact that he played D4 D5 so quickly so
certainly just as you were mentioning
VAR
um
he's got a natural touch absolutely and
this is still lots of theory here guys I
have about 50 games in a database here
50. and I can tell Wesley knows this so
after the move D5 uh black has two
options can take on D5 he takes D5 or
play the move in ibd7 so this is what he
is thinking and the white is actually a
little bit better
because of the leading development and
if you take on D5 Bishop D5 let's say if
you try to Castle then there is a move
Bishop takes F6 and now you cannot take
back with the queen because you're going
to lose the pawn on B7 so you have to
take back with the pawn and now your
king position is a little bit weak so
white will be better there that's just
too ugly after D5 you play the move
let's say Knight bd7 yeah then you're
gonna run into an idea like Knight D4
and this is also looking good for white
so I think Wesley is doing really well
so far okay uh with the move D5 yeah
just surprised put the Magnus in the
freeze there yeah goes down on time so
that's that's looking good for a wisely
so exactly instead of the move Bishop B4
I'm a little bit more familiar with C7
C6 earlier and just to kind of avoid
ideas like day five yes exactly that's
the main move yeah sir yeah that that so
so here this move D5 is really uh put
Magnus on the back foot again castles
Knight D4 it's easy to see that this
bishop on C3 is eyeballing potential
Bishop F6 and
and G7 Pawn uh like it or not I'm
thinking Knight D7 is is box or what we
would call forced and quickly no Knight
D4 but quickly by Wesley a capture I
guess Wesley is is contemplating Queen
E2
and creating a weak Pawn 96 exactly
before we win them we gotta weaken them
never heard them before
Queen E2 Queen E2 uh still Theory bar
still Theory but only six games played
in a database here and uh statistically
white should be doing well I've seen
lots of draws lots of draws in this
position
Queenie two plate uh two times and also
a bishop takes e66 four times wow Bishop
E6 was more popular I thought Queen E2
was automatic he did take on E6 and
they're going into a three versus three
I see is wide I mean uh the way Wesley
took on E6 he seems to be sure that why
it's going to be better in the end game
but is it really that big of an
advantage I would say a lot more minor
Advantage than he did if he had played
Mini 2 immediately but who knows again
Wesley on the clock at least is saying
my preparation is outstanding what about
yours
Magnus Castle
hey I'm thinking very close
maybe the question is like if I play
Rook D1 anticipating
check and dropping back with the King
maybe this bishop is really putting a
considerable pressure and there we go he
didn't play Rook to D1 he played Rook to
E1
looking to drop back with this King and
not getting his root clear right now
Magnus could play Knight D5 allow Bishop
G7 and go Rook G8
that way he can free his night right now
exactly that and this may be that key
moment that he needs maybe rookie won a
little an exact maybe Rook D1 to avoid
to avoid what what you just said but uh
okay this is I I feel for that we're
getting into a critical moment and we
just don't want to be in a long-term
situation where the bishop is eyeing is
there a freeing chance with Knight D5
because he's done it 95 is definitely a
possible move here if you just play Rook
HCA King F1 white is just better there
it's just a little bit annoying because
you're gonna have problems moving your
knight from F6 and also you have to
watch out for ideas like Knight G5 at
some point so probably you have to play
the move H6 and you really tied up there
and so just passive here most likely
you're probably gonna hold if you don't
make any big mistakes but this is more
concrete here and now Bishop G7 needs to
be played otherwise you don't have
anything so rook hg8 and now is a
critical move Bishop H6 because you
really need to cover the F4 square right
inviting Rook takes G2 but it's not like
The Rook is doing terrible terrible
things Rook takes G2 with the bishop on
H6 it can play
81 and King F1 and the bishop might play
tease on G5 sorry yeah I think what it's
just easier to play with the bishop yes
in Blitz especially right but like far
said with
with the accurate play of course it
should be very close to equal and the
Wesley doesn't take he goes Bishop D4
I find that move surprising uh I thought
Bishop G7 was very very compelling
Bishop D4 now you need F6 right now you
can play shut down the bishop
and F6 does two things actually it does
shut down the bishop but it also shuts
down the Knight he played F6 and you
mentioned Knight G5 could be it could
have been awkward uh a move or two ago
that that I don't know guys but now also
C5 coming up guys where is the bishop
gonna go now yeah I think it's King F1
C5 maybe C4 maybe bishop E3 this feels
like it's beginning to look too Josh
what was our backup game
Gary just just get an eye on that if you
don't mind bar and tell me if it worth
uh stealing away or not mvl rapper Game
let's stay on this one for a little bit
more the other game is also looks uh
kind of equal dry symmetrical so let's
see if we'll have some more development
here so B3 played by Wesley is trying to
secure that B2 Square for the bishop
after the move C5 yeah
by the way I feel like commentators
curse because just a moment ago now see
you said are we ever going to see around
where all five games are drawn and go no
next round you know
uh C5 Bishop B2 Knight B8 the Knight on
D7 was no great shakes I must say I do
like the idea of opening up the rook and
bringing the Knight to a little bit more
Freer square if I can use that term C5
C4 possibility because if you do take
Knight to B6 and recapturing the pawn C5
C4 has got my my attention how about you
how would you like to play the Black is
completely fine okay because after F6 I
think uh White's advantage that was the
better Bishop is gone because Bishop is
not better than Black's Knights anymore
in my opinion so
I think Wesley shouldn't take risks here
maybe shut it down personally I do like
night detail as I said Wesley shouldn't
take risks G4 well you you did say I
mean come on uh you did say uh your
Bishop was getting shut down so the idea
of G4 G5 I think a lot of people would
find that compelling uh just grabbing
some space I did like Knight D2 possibly
to reroute the Knight to E4 the Knight
on F3 for me I believe it looked passive
the main reason was Liz put in pressure
with G4 is because Magnus is down to 30
seconds hello and Wesley has two minutes
so that's significant Wesley feels like
he has a chance now far that I mean you
you said it yourself you've played a lot
if not hundreds of games with
Wesley and you know when he's ahead on
time he's he's a monster absolutely yes
and his time management is excellent
here he's got nearly two minutes versus
30 seconds for Magnus and you know now
he's got this G5 idea that is it's still
annoying because he wants to open up the
diagonal nh6 it's not going to solve all
the problems still he can play the move
H4 there so now Magnus goes King K7 by
the way I found the move Rook
D1 to E1 to be ambitious probably the
best move to begin with but also a move
that says I want to keep pieces on the
board I want to play for a win
absolutely now G5 is a good move as well
now creating the weaknesses it captures
captures the Knight on F3 needs a better
Square immediately I love this move
right totally wrong about White's
position big Advantage for white guys
yeah I wasn't squeezed out a very nice
Advantage out of that what I thought was
very equal position agreed and you don't
see Magnus going down to five seconds on
the clock wow seven seven seconds Wesley
keeps playing in this style I think he
has a very good chance of converting
this oh and I love this move Knight back
to F3 I was I was arguing that the pawn
on F6 was was freezing the night now
that the pawn is on F5 look at this
it's just probing day one check now in
96. love it immediate 96 as well where
does The Rook go F7 oh I see Rook D1
check first drive the king then I like
it he's done it he's from your lips to
uh the chessboard oh
okay that is counter play
oh darn it that is counter play Magnus
loves counter play he does have six
seconds on the clock and that's a pass
Pawn H pawns passers must be pushed oh
Knight F7 will run into Rook H7 was H4
Miss Time bar
it I think it's fine now he he had to
move Knight F7 there that would have
been very strong yes
yes he can pick up and he'll be up a
pawn and uh really good winning chances
for Wesley here and here we go we're
gonna be in a night ending I don't think
where the weakness change oh my gosh I
agree with you I don't think Magnus
should have said but D3 was a good move
right before white was ready to play
King D2 to D3 takes Bond
C4 not separating his pawns oh and look
at it oh this should be winning
completely winning completely winning
even my pick
before and then pick up the same and by
the way if Wesley were to win this game
yes he he's beating an informed Magnus I
mean I was just gonna say that to defeat
Magnus when he's in foreign
that is really really impressive Knight
E2 it's still not over but the night is
going to be coming night to see three I
was about to say Knight C3 to D5 was
playing itself
but uh
I I I remember I was in Oslo for the
Fisher random world championship and
Wesley just clobbered
uh Magnus in the final championship
match and it reminds me of the form that
Wesley
got hell King G5 and I think Magnus is
gonna
toss in the towel really soon wow
and Wesley just outplayed Magnus that
that's exactly right he really did
there's just no other way of putting it
we hear that Kiri has drawn his game
against Duda
a game that MBL an mvl won his game
against Rich report talk about a
comeback I mean so it wasn't coming
later's car so we didn't get five draws
and look at that Magnus uh
that was really one-sided and Magnus
knows uh Wesley just played an
incredibly good game kept Advantage from
start to finish what do you have for his
uh of our all games are finished and we
have how many four results I think 80
again Lavon won his game oh that was
important boy tashek won his game in mvl
won the game so we only have one drop
between Duda and Gary there we go 80
percent uh over to you bar a great break
breakdown round two a little bit for us
yeah the game that caught my eye is the
votation game he he won the first game
if you remember against Magnus and and
then he didn't win any game since then
but now he won this very good game I
think against uh dayak here and I want
to show you this interesting moment in
this game here so in this position he
just played the move uh the B5 which is
sacrificing a pawn but it's a position
upon sacrifice because after Bishop
takes F6 if you take GTX F6 Knight C3
will come back black is still doing okay
but your king position is we second so
he played the move Queen F6 allowing the
movement ib6 and now rook d8 and now he
has two Bishops and open D file as well
and he managed really to outplay his
opponent here Queen E6 now attacking the
Knight forcing the move Knight C3 and
now he played 95 and then he got the
opportunity to put a knight on D3 and it
was it was extremely strong here just
couple of more moves Knight G5
Queen H6
F4 and Knight is coming to D3 here and
this Knight was very very strong here
just making it very difficult for white
to move and he went on to win the game
here which page four Bishop B6 F5 now
removing the knight from E4 Knight C3
and now all the pieces are in the game
and black white white spaces are very
very cramped it's very hard to do
anything here The Rook on a file for
example is trapped you're down upon but
you have a very good compensation here
and Bishop F6
and now putting some pressure on B3 and
also B2 so here it's already a very big
advantage and at the end he won exchange
and won this game another game that I
was keep an eye on is the anishkiri game
and that that game ended in a draw it
was a very solid game that ended in uh
to Rook end game that uh just a equal
Pawn structure so they end up making a
draw here
and our standing after two very eventful
uh Blitz rounds
changes at the top
see what they are
and here we go so if we look at the
current scores young Crystal today still
in the solid but only half a point lead
now exactly born Iranian is catching
with 13 points and a very big victory by
Wesley he keeps him in the running clear
third place and now mvl is in clear
fourth since Magnus just had a loss
against Wesley so we have five Magnus in
the fifth place and Richard's still in
the sixth place
and let's jump over to our friends in
Warsaw
and speaking of mvl and Richie Rapport
they're definitely having some sort of a
French discussion because uh they've
been playing a French in Bucharest they
played it in the rapid with the same
colors and the other is always white a
report is always black and I have to say
report has been scoring quite well and
it feels like mvl is getting good
positions he also told me that I feel
frustrated because I'm getting good
positions yet I'm not able to win those
games let's take a look at what happened
in this game E46 we get the French and
now this move Knight to E2 previously
we've seen the winner with E5 Knight to
E2 take on e4 and this is what we got I
have to say I was pleasantly surprised
by the fact that white got a pretty
significant Advantage out of the opening
but at this point the easy castle would
have been much better for the simple
fact that what you want to do is focus
on the king side it's a bit
counter-intuitive because you do want to
allow yourself to potentially push the
pawns G4 H4 G5 as maybe we have in the
game but Castle was the better move
because after that you go Queen to G4
Rook to E1 Bishop to E5 and then slowly
slowly bring your pieces towards the
king it doesn't matter that your king is
also you don't need the pawns you only
need the pieces rookie one rookie three
swing The Rook on the third Rank and
this would give uh White quite a
significant advantage and take a look at
uh what happened later on we were having
some debacle going on in this position
Bishop G5 you cannot take that [__]
don't touch that Bishop you get
checkmated in a couple of moves for
example if you take take that's a check
King G8 Queen H7 Checkmate very very
typical
poison Bishop exactly we usually have
the poison Pawn this was the poison
Bishop this was a critical moment he
took on H6 but the much better move
would have been to take on A3 and now of
course if you take on G7 I take on G7 if
you do take on A3 I'm going to give you
a Perpetual Queen to B3 Queen 283 Queen
to B3 Queen to A3 and that's going to be
a draw he did not spot this he took on
H6 and allow Queen to E5 which in fact
just gives white a tremendous Advantage
my king is safer than yours and that's
all that matters in this position but
let's take a look later on in the game
white was having an amazing Advantage
but Queen to D5 lost the advantage for
this specific reason after Rook to F3
black had the move Queen to D6 which
forces the trade of the queens and
that's a problem Rook to F7 King to H6
you cannot hide the queen you can go to
H1 but then I take on D1 and I follow it
up with Rook to E1 that changes the
queens and that kills your attack and uh
this basically uh is better for black
it's going to be a pawn out for black so
golden opportunity for Richie he did not
find it he played Queen to G4 and after
that he got checkmated very quickly as
we can see Rook takes it to Rook to H5
nice game by mvl finally he gets his
first victory in the French against
Richie Anastasia what game did you watch
I was checking the game between
played this like solid he decided to
play some solid line Auntie Berlin and
everything went fine until the moment
when I think Levant simply outplayed him
positionally at certain point
um so there were like um he kind of
understood probably better the pawn
structure this move C5 was very
important then he took on before and in
the end kiril ended up with this D3 Pawn
which was weakened before upon as well
so he had to defend both of them and you
know it's not that easy he had some
opportunities to take maybe on D6 and
then play Rook C1 something like that
and just try to keep this position but
he decided to maneuver with his Knight
and actually one also but I think Lyon
was just playing better he moved his
Knight on the six and you know F4 Square
D4 Square there are some problems with
them definitely so after 96 it was
really hard so I would C5 also came
after that and I think here Leon could
maybe play Not So straightforward he
took everything he took the pawn on D3
maybe he could try to play something
like Knight F4 opening for 92 all and
you know maybe it would give him a
little bit like say more Advantage but
he decided to go straight forward he
just took the pawn on D3 and of course
descending was really difficult to hold
there were a couple of still very funny
moments so I mean I liked it very much
this is still got some activity level
one was defending absolutely great I
mean he kept the pawn on A6 but there
was this nice moment I liked a lot
um so the king went to H4 all the way so
he made this pin and then the Rook A7
very tricky move he wants to play Knight
C6 so what to do here the only way for
black to keep the advantage was to play
like rookies Rook A4 with the idea of
Knight C6 then Bishop C6 yes so it was
not possible and you know slowly looking
just really you can get six so black is
getting much better he missed this
chance it was of course they had the
seconds at this moment so let's say he
pushed the pawn and at one point you
know she still managed to trick him very
nice game a lot of explosive chess and
as we get ready for the next break we do
have a slight segment for you guys what
did the players think of rapid and Blitz
[Music]
this tournament has both rapid and Blitz
time formats which format do you prefer
and which one do you think plays more
into your strengths
yeah I like boots the most definitely
but maybe I'm better than rapid I mean
it's difficult to say actually but I
remember when I consider rapid to be my
least favorite
uh you know what I'm controlled but I
was like the most successful in it in
the past I mean I was like European
champion and so on yeah but basically
anything but classical even though it's
very fine it's just fun you know to play
and uh I'm looking back I think like
most of the chess players they love
playing Blitz the most but for some
people you know they love it but they
are not as good as they help they are I
don't know I think I used to because I
focus on the classical chess much more
in the past I used to be my specialty
much more so because I play so much more
Accent on the preparation and less on
let's say skills in the time scrambles
and all that
I think there were more rapid implicit
events recently so maybe I'll get a
little bit a little bit more rounded but
I'm still not a specialist in Rapid and
Blitz
but you know I'm having a lot of fun
playing rapid Blitzer and especially
play so much online over the board is
different because things are moving
quickly
it gets a little physical sometimes so
yeah I'm looking um looking forward I
always would prefer a longer format uh
if I prefer classical and then rapid and
then Blitz just because
uh chess is about strategy and then
there's a lot more time to think in rap
it's like I used to do very well in
Rapid maybe some time back like I wanted
2018 but uh we'll see what happens I
don't know it's very hard to say like
when I was younger I used to love 25
plus 10 as if you know why it was kind
of perpetious but still super slow but
now I'm kind of old and unpatient and
you know I can't calculate anyway so and
all the video events are with um 15 plus
10 so it's kind of strange for me to
play any of these time controls actually
but like I think that's five plus two
Blitz is very tricky I mean since we are
playing C plus two and three plus two is
just just way quicker so yeah like last
year I got completely smashed in
fortnite so obviously it must be the 25
which I prefer yeah I don't know which
one I will prefer but I think here
um Blitz might be easier for me because
as I said I'm the last rated then in
Blitz you can expect something more uh
dramatic
so I think it will be more uh random so
it can help me
prefer to play The Blitz but my friends
tell me that I'm I'm a better rapid
player so I I generally love playing
Short Time Performance because
there's not much preparation and it's
more about coming up with surprising
ideas
um that's a that's a good good question
because I used to play Blitz a lot
not not online but over the boards when
in Ukraine there was a lot of
tournaments about it I think I played
less Rapids but it's hard to demand what
is my favorite time control because I
think Gucci's player tops player has to
be good in everything
I mean I've learned to like
what bit more than I used to but in
general I think it's
kind of the ultimate format for the
audience for the players you can just
play a bunch of those don't not get
tires like he can play casually and you
can play it in more serious and
competitive fashion like we are doing
here and
in general I have this ability to play
fast and put a lot of pressure on and
the clock my opponents of course in less
time
there is to play the the best I am
I've generally done pretty well in in
Rapid in in the grand chess tour
in terms of what I like I probably like
to prefer Bliss but I like both
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
everyone as we review our standings
after two rounds of Blitz update is
still in the solid closely following
Livonia Iranian and Wesley Stone in the
clear third place after a huge Victory
against Magnus Carlson it's tied at the
top yes yeah in the fourth place is mvl
and in the fifth Magnus Carlson yeah
that was a big slip to Wesley so Magnus
uh overreaching maybe with the
Scandinavian and then uh the rest of the
field tell us about the pairings for
this round three we avoid tashek bunch
of chenko Carlson against the yak
Rapport again so Geary against MBL and
Iranian against Judah we will be our
future featured matchup aronian versus a
Duda and they have started Vienna
interesting Lavon basically saying I've
been watching the games of Richie report
and uh
I'm kind of inspired not the Dracula
variation with uh what what what is it
Knight C6 this is still Theory F4 I
queen H5 yes Queen H5 is I'm I was
expecting Knight C6 in this crazy line
that goes Knight to D5 Knight to B5 G6
but F4 a little bit off the Beaten Track
I want to say uh VAR yes or very rare
rare move guys only four games played uh
the other two moves are very popular
they're Queen takes C5 and Knight F3 uh
dozens of games played but F4 is very
rare so definitely the one is trying to
surprise do that here after F4 we have
it takes four D4
quickly castles uh G7 G6 was a thought a
fleeting thought at the very least as
was the move Bishop H4 check
Levon is absolutely not interested in
recapturing upon it it seems he's down
two pawns but is this what did the
statistics tell us of our about this
opening is this good for white I I'm
doubtful well we don't even have any
games in a database in this position
here but here actually engines really
want to play this move Knight E8 and I
think the idea is to be able to play the
move D6 or maybe c65 at some point
because you really want to shut down the
light Square Bishop here and the Knight
on D6 is blockading the d-pawn so after
98 uh the violation is in favor for
black okay and uh probably Levon has
some deep analysis that he prepared
mostly for Blitz here but I will show
you after 98 if you place this move one
of the options is actually to play the
move 95. immediately to put pressure on
F7 because now you have three attackers
on it so you're forcing the move G6 okay
and now Queen will Retreat on F3 and now
trying to pick up the pawn on F4 and
again apply more pressure on F7 and here
there is a line with D6 here and also
you can play the move Knight C6 I would
be she has played 96 right away Knight
C6 right away no Knight E8 and after
Knight C6 Bishop takes F4 G7 G6 on the
board
yes now I think the only move for white
is Queen H3 which he played rather
quickly you don't want to put it on H6
because that's going to run into a
knight F5 so right can H3 makes sense so
it's possible they won't still analyze
this position and now we could see the
move Knight F5 plate putting pressure on
the four now long Castle makes a lot of
sense right and now
perhaps the move D6 just try to open up
the diagonal for the bishop definitely
going to play G4 yes he's not interested
in getting bounced around with this
queen Knight F5 on the board
so we could see something like this
happening G4 Knight G7 and Ambush page
six with long castling yes okay
um
it's funny because with the queen on H3
you know it's I find myself attracted to
short castling nightly yeah Sean casting
Knight takes because I'm thinking that
this bishop on F7 right
if my king were pardon me if my Rook
were on F1 I mean I've got
some types of combinations with Rook F7
and queen H7 because he castled long
um nothing to be done D7 D6 G4
I think that this is uh going to be a
very very exciting Blitz game and in
terms of Blitz for Duda he's facing some
I want to say high level prep for a
Blitz game this is almost unfair right I
mean you know when your opponent comes
with a sizzling novelty in a classical
game the normal thing is to sit and
think for 30 minutes you have time right
to figure out what's going on here not
in Blitz we have about five seconds the
week can move against a well-prepared
opponent uh dude is in in serious
difficulties here now the position isn't
bad it's just that he's going to be
facing an enormous attack on the king
side after G4 G4
and you really want to play uh to open
up the king side I think livon is still
in his prep he's making moves so quickly
he sure is uh
VAR this is this is something very
impressive uh preparation by I mean I
don't know what the engine is saying the
engine eval I mean from a practical
point of view not easy for black
absolutely an opponent is playing very
fast and now Knight D5 played looks like
you're gonna have to give up your dark
Square Bishop it's it's very annoying in
Blitz to be cut in a preparation and a
position like this where there's lots of
threats now Knight takes E7 Queen takes
E7 Knight G5 perhaps Rook H E1 it's so
much easier to play and we see about two
minute time Advantage for level one and
this is a critical game if you can win
this game he's gonna get closer and very
very important he missed an opportunity
in a rapid game against Judah so he
definitely wants to try to win this but
we know Duda is very slippery he had
some shaky positions so far in this
tournament in Rapid portion but he
didn't lose any of them just lost one in
Blitz only half a point behind Judah so
if he wins here
yeah
very very important could you tell me
about the clock times which is uh yeah
so that's down to one minute and 10
seconds and the bone has three and a
half minutes C7 C6 more than three times
time Advantage now that's huge forcing
Lavon to do something he really wants to
do which is to take this put his Rook on
E1 put his Knight on G5
yes and uh gift me the checkmate
um
how is it looking in terms of the
defense I I'm not seeing it uh VAR
Knight takes E7 Queen takes E7 rookie
one Bishop E6
Knight G5
it looks very very promising for white
which Rook you want to put only one that
was it I was hoping you would bail me up
I said rookie one and yeah okay if we're
playing the blindfold game yeah because
actually you can play both moves and
sometimes in this type of positions you
want to leave The Rook on each one
because h4h5 in so actually let's take a
look at the move rule with de1 okay
attacking the queen and here black needs
to play uh either Queen D7 or queen C7
okay so let's let's put it on
responded with Queen H4 Queen H4 is a
move as well because now he wants to go
Queen F6 and our Queen d8 is one option
he played F6 rather quickly I must say
and h2h3 just defending the pawn on G4
quick engine eval even though I don't
think that makes much sense in a Blitz
game where it's better for white but not
that much it's like 0.5 okay and some
options are here to play the move B6
Bishop B7 just connect the Rooks and the
black will put the black will put the
Rook on F7 here I'm just going to
refresh my board everybody don't get
angry A6 a7a5 I thinking I want to
double my Rooks right uh E3 Rook E1 Rook
H2 Rook E2 it's like
4.7 I know uh pick and choose absolutely
you can also play the move rookie three
I don't like the move A5 it seems like
he's just trying to create but I like
rookie 3 because in particular if you
play the move A4 I can even play the
move B4 that was why that was stopping
rookie yeah that stops also the A3 idea
so very very risky move a A5 here I see
the reason why Rook H2 might be
important Rook H2 rookie 8 invites
Bishop takes G7 and then I can grab the
e-file whereas if I play Rook E3 Rook E8
I'm not completely winning control
immediately over the e-file so uh
important moment again clock times
because Levon is caught up uh with Duda
so they are both about one minute now on
the clock first place upper grabs the
outcome of this game and the problem
here guys I think it's just too many
good options when you have all these
options it's hard to pick which one
going to
six instead
it is this one was the least appealing I
I understand I I like going after uh
weakies too but A4 92 okay let's bring
the night over to defend the queen side
but this Rook was doing nothing how does
black defend F6 well if I go a b you
want to play Rook F6 and allow Rook A1
check a knight B1 yes oh
I think it's just winning for Whitefish
because Rook A1 will be met by Knight B1
uh because of that the only move here is
G5 G5 okay now I'm warming up to Rook F1
if there we go Rook takes F6 he's
invited Rook A1 Knight B1 and you you
said VAR this is just over
yes this is just winning now he can he
can just play the move Rook F1 yeah
and by the way we have a big update that
mvl beat giri already with the black
pieces wow
oh a promising start for Anish for today
is not paying off he did not play Rook
F1 he played C2 takes B3 a move I fully
understand because black is still in big
big trouble here uh White has quite a
number of good options he's just traded
on E8 oh I think black's counter play is
looking very promising
winning for black what but he didn't
play it he played Bishop D7
goodness this is really a topsy-turvy
game it looked look why it might have it
but I guess King C2 is the only move not
to lose for Levon now King C2 inviting
Queenie for check and he plays it wow
remarkable walking right into the check
I mean holy smokes that is not an easy
move too players by the way played I'll
do the two seconds on the clock clock
two seconds yeah he didn't flag
he played his move and Levon now down to
two seconds and
Rook F6 oh my gosh move the Knight he's
done it
and he's
and clock times again apologies just two
seconds
three seconds oh he could have played
Bishop takes G7 he didn't
oh it still looks very good for White
Knight F6 check no oh we're going to the
end game
but we have opposite color Bishops
um
shaking his head uh
uh I think Lavon just like has led his
opponent hold on Knight takes H3 G5 is
that Knight getting trapped do that two
seconds King D4
why did he go King Seafood
but white also cannot take it
but okay but it's just pingy five in
Domination this looks winning before
the night can go to E6
yeah this looks like it should be
winning one time and we have a new
tournament leader yes and we haven't
been able to say that since the first
two rounds when in the Rapids 4-0 start
for Duda so we have to quickly jump to
Wesley's game
Wes
Ley won the second game in a row
look at the people he's beating he just
went through Magnus Carlson and he just
took care of a close rival uh Richie
before
are we sure he won because I
I draw I've got a draw listed wait a
minute we may have been premature
we we have a draw oh we have a draw I
think so he was winning
he was winning what
it was a draw UH 60 results uh Vara
Gotta Throw it to you because I'm still
kind of catching up on that game of
Lavon mentally uh that was quite the
duel for first place absolutely it was a
crazy game dude I'm missing the win when
he had the opportunity to play the move
Queen E4 but Leon strategy paid off here
and now he's leading the tournament and
chefchenko winning another game here and
I like how he activated his rook in this
position against voitashek so let me
show you how he won in this position
here so in this position it's very
important to get this Rook on the second
rank here so he played the move Rook C8
attacking the queen
Queen to B2 and now Rook comes in on a
second Rank and again now the only thing
left is to try to land the queen on F2
here and try to attack on a second rank
so Queen takes B7 now Bishop H3
excellent idea if knife takes you have
the move Knight F3 here and he played
the move Queen B3 check King G7
Bishop takes C5 and now simply Queen C5
check and the next move is going to be
if you go to H1 Bishop G2 mate King F1
Queen F2 and chefchenko winning his
second game he is a very very good Blitz
player here and he proved in this game
so another game uh I have here is the
report so this game actually just ended
and ended in a draw here it was a is a
crazy game with lots of lots of
complications uh it looks like the final
position is actually winning for black
but we have a result showing a draw in
this position there's a queen C2 move
apparently and now King F1 Queen takes
B3 and in this case now if you do a lot
of the deflections your queen is hanging
and if you play the move Knight C4 you
can play King C5 so we have a draw
results in this game but looks like the
final position is winning for Wesley so
back to you guys
thank you uh VAR indeed and uh let's
just sneak in a look at the standings
and we're gonna just see how how uh
shake shake them up for us solid live
onion with 14 points
Kristoff do this only scored a half out
of three yeah he's not having a good
start but Wesley Wesley Mr apparently Mr
wind but still in the sharing third
place because MPL won a game against
Danish where he was completely busted
yeah and um how did Magnus do draw oh my
God so he's at 50 after three rounds but
let's throw it over to work Warsaw and
get a A View From uh the crazed capital
of chess
well speaking of uh Magnus uh guys I'm
going to call it the way I see it Magnus
has not found his shape up to this point
with the white pieces against Bogdan
Daniel Dak he was surely looking for a
victory but unfortunately for him he
didn't get it and he was in fact in
trouble he could have easily lost this
game with the white pieces take a look
and we're going to jump over the opening
because this is something that he played
against nepalnyashi in the world
championship match in Dubai this exact
same position Queen to D7 this is all
theory in uh the Petrov you cannot take
on D5 because of course Bishop takes H2
that is a discovery uh check and picking
up the queen game over A4 take on D5
take on B5 take on B5 and now A5 is very
important that you get rid of this
weakness on a7s black and you offer wide
options you can take on A6 and that's
going to probably simplify the position
into a draw or you can leave my Pawn on
A5 leave the pawn on B5 which doesn't
allow my knight to come into play easily
nevertheless leaving the pawn on A5
alive that's a very very dangerous
Affair for White Knight H4 by the way
still following that game between Magnus
and nepo G6 Bishop to H6 and I have to
say this is uh the novelty but it's not
a great novelty it's a very risky one of
course it makes a lot of sense you want
to establish this uh grip on the King on
G8 Rook to C8 you can never touch the
pawn on C3 unless you have control over
the eighth rank with the bishop on H6
very very nice but unfortunately after
G4 Knight to D7 I'm starting to look at
that C3 Pawn because my Rook on A8 is
defending the E8 Square Knight to G2
Rook takes C3 and I have to say this is
just a pawn up and by the way Magnus was
spending a lot of time uh that not so
much wow and he had a golden up we know
the the bow down time travel so I think
he called it Magnus
Knight to E3 and he played Bishop to f8
which equalizes the position but doesn't
give black the advantage that he has in
this position he has a decisive
Advantage if he plays the following
sequence Rook to D3 going for the D4
Pawn shirt Knight takes D5 makes a lot
of sense the problem is and maybe this
is something that he missed is that
after Rook takes D4 you know not only
picked up the pawn on D4 but you're also
looking at that G4 Pawn so Knight to E7
take take and now I can take on G4 it
looks scary right because that bishopone
H6 Rook to E1 is coming Rook to E8 maybe
you get checkmate and perhaps this is
very scarce here I think this is what he
was worried but you can just simply take
another pawn and then go Knight to f8
followed by Knight to E6 which blocks
the action on the E5 golden opportunity
he did not play this Bogdan and they
found more or less all the exchanges in
the position after that easy draw for a
bug done he was actually having the
upper hand but he were following an
absolutely
absolutely crazy game it was such a
crazy battle you know at the beginning
it was it seemed like Maxime was playing
very sharp
he played very sharp opening and at the
end actually this queen couldn't find
the piece at the center of the board so
he was moving it left and right and
still even at the moment Anish proposed
The Exchange no exchanges we keep
playing you know Checkmate is more
important and you can see Bishop which
four it seems like black is now will
give a Checkmate four pieces on the king
side but no the engine is saying plus
four yes already so white was actually
was doing fine yes but I will I will
show you what happened after after Queen
F3 it turned out that black has no any
attack I mean pieces are all hanging so
he had to play this Knight H6 and after
Bishop H6 simply look what's going on
now Queen F7 and then this king is in
trouble
it looks like completely computer gives
plus six I think is having a heart
attack now in the plays players area and
D5 great move the best in this position
and now look what happened at this
moment any move was Undisputed I heard
what they were talking about he said the
Kennywood would win this position
exactly but yeah no you know you have to
match want to play this Knight D5 move
yes so he played this Knight D5 thinking
there is a Checkmate but there was no
Checkmate can you imagine so Maxim found
a way how to you know stabilize his
position Rook State and Knight B8 very
very good moves and probably what time
is what he missed yes he missed my bed
but he's maybe here he still thought
that he's winning because look at this
queen E5 and Rook King F7 you think that
you play Rook B8 and you're winning
because Rook D7 is coming look if black
takes some B8 I will just take on the
seven Checkmate is comment right because
of King Jade at least you will click
here so your pissed up life is good but
but it didn't happen in the game in the
game it was completely crazy moment
because now Maxine found the best move
Queen history in this position
intermediate move so what's going on
here if King H1 Rook H3
you're the one getting checkmated
unbelievable it's not it's now it's uh
actually Gary who would get checkmated
because after all these moves I mean uh
Queen F3 and he takes one second so here
at this moment the last attempt he
played King give one but again Maxine
found the best move finally castling for
black Rook f8 threaded in King Jade to
finish artificial castling and win the
game so if you give a Check Yes
I haven't seen it for a long time this
was just absolutely crazy game and I saw
the players they came out still talking
you know peacefully but I'm sure both of
them were really nervous inside
absolutely mad scenes here in Poland
guys back to you in the studio what a
hot game wow that was really really a
turnaround as the computers gave a huge
Advantage for Anish
um before we jump to a very short break
I just want to check in with our friends
at Q Boutique and see what's special
there is for today here we go we have
this gray men's jacket celebrating the
annual Grand chest tour makes the
perfect addition to any chess player's
wardrobe features the logo or the grand
Chester on the top left of the jacket
and a full-length zipper 60 cotton 40
polyester available only a cute Boutique
St louis.com shop there for all your
chest needs and we will see you on the
other side of the Sprite
for the first time since 2020 the
world's best female chess players
converging the chess capital of America
St Louis Missouri for the Third Edition
of the Karens cup beginning June 3rd
players will compete for a 180 000 prize
fund
this tournament features 10 of the top
female chess players in the world
including returning Champion humpy
koneru along with top-rated American
Irina Crush
it's one of the most decisive classical
tournaments in chess that you won't want
to miss catch all the action on the
Saint Louis chess club YouTube and
twitch channels
[Music]
the muni's premier season bursting with
comedies romance and Magic Begins June
12th with the muni premiere of beautiful
the Carole King musical
the Epic summer continues with Disney's
Beauty and the Beast chess West Side
Story Little Shop of Horrors rent and
Sister Act
single tickets are now on sale at
muni.org
[Music]
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why Jess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
hello everyone and welcome back these
are our standings up to three rounds of
Blitz
I certainly did that
live on in the first place young and
second and Sharon third Wesleyan MBL wow
MBL was making an incredible comeback
Maggie on the outside looking in there's
a three two and a half point gap between
him and first he still has to win a
couple of games to catch up he's in the
fifth place right now and let us know uh
set the table for us for round four what
are the pairings we have Chef Chancellor
plain Duda MBO against aronia that's got
to be our Marquee matchup Wesley against
Geary our plan B and dierk against
Robert and white against man Carlson
okay that will be plan C but that mvl
versus Iranian uh suddenly uh VAR that's
uh that's the biggest Clash
yeah I think uh by the way white Tasha
Carlson Carlson's looking for Revenge
because he lost the first game against
him in the Rapids that was how they
started yeah and uh well are we going to
see polish again no I don't think so uh
VAR a little bit uh Maggie's had an
overreach he played the Polish he played
the Scandinavian self-inflicted wounds
but when his opponents got the
opportunity they played really well
absolutely and we saw that Christian was
showing the arc had an opportunity to
defeat him as well so it was impressive
first round win in a blitz portion but
the next two games weren't as as great
here so he really needs to have a nice
streak of wins in this format the next
few rounds because otherwise I think the
Gap is going to be just simply too big
talk about the mvl Lavone that's for
first place at the moment Lavon half a
point over Duda how well I mean that
they played so many games uh how would
you describe the matchup between those
two players the matchup is incredible I
remember in the World Cup 2017 where
level wanted Armageddon actually against
mvl to qualify to the candidates
tournament but they went back and forth
there were some big games that mvl won
also against Levon so this two two
players have been just battling for many
many years and I think anything can
happen in this game they both are
incredibly strong in Blitz format you
feel that they're both informed as well
absolutely definitely the one is playing
really good chess and now nvl he has two
out of three the same same for Levon as
well two out of three and I think they
they're in good shape here so critical
game here if if Levon wins that will
give lots of confidence and if mvl can
turn around and win as well this will
give him some chances as well because we
still have lots of Blitz Games remaining
now see you're in the hot seat Envia
with white against Lavon how are you
going to predict the outcome
who's winning
I'm going to say MBL because
after the way he won the last game
Anastasia was super happy right right
The Rook f8 move he found after that he
must be feeling so good that exactly it
might uh bring him another win in this
one but again there's Lavon he's a wild
card think of any player in the world
other than Magnus Carlson you only have
a week to prepare for the tournament
you're invited to the tournament as a
wild card the galaxy of stars
Wild Card dude is in first place
he's amazing amazing player and we were
talking about that on break together VAR
and you were saying the reason is is he
works so incredibly hard absolutely yeah
he regularly trains and you know he's
got a very good routine and you know he
just likes to work on chess in general
it's not like he waits like he's got a
tournament then he starts working so he
just works on chess pretty much every
day and I think for him getting the call
for this I think he was just very
excited to come back to the grantchester
the first year he's actually not a tour
participant to have an opportunity to
play in this in this event and he did
really well last year as well I think he
finished second here behind dudas so I'm
not surprised he's doing really well
because he's just incredibly strong in
this rapid templates format what a
wonderful Choice as a wild card truly
truly
and as usual Maggie's just uh oh nope
he's at the boys I apologize and you're
ready for Revenge but uh after that
beautiful start against MBL in round one
of the blitz uh Maggie's only scored 50
after three Wesley really played a
fantastic game against him and outplayed
him so I'm sure that stumbled him a
little bit yeah that was it and the dioc
game could have easily gone wrong and
this is our Marquee matchup as these two
Gladiators they've taken the full
measure of one another over the years
um I don't know some very good friends
off the board yes they are they really
enjoy a good game of Avalon I I I've
been in those uh moments of Avalon with
them
um I'm going to be the contrarian here
I'm going to go with a draw but I'm
going to say that both sides missed
opportunities to win absolutely after
seeing the Anish game when I saw the
opening in my mind I already put one
zero for a niche right it was like
incredible completely winning and then
then somehow and we all comes back and
and wins in again once again if you give
mvl chances I feel like he really excels
in this kind of sharp complicated
positions I think his calculation is
extremely strong and you know somehow he
just defended that King looked like it
was going to get checkmated in the
middle of the board but he simply
escaped and won the game against Anish
tactical awareness is absolutely
phenomenal E4 E5 and they are off I will
always be seeing uh I was about to say
Berlin yes oh yes now he takes E4
and rookie one
so again this is It's become so topical
they've even allowed these lines with
Knight takes B5 variations
um I think Levant just played this in
the rapid yesterday he played Bishop D3
and then Bishop F or was that in Petra I
was in a petrol okay yeah yeah it is
rookie too uh shades of the uh world
championship between Magnus and Sergey
kariakin rookie two looks like a very
funny move inviting B6 Rook to E1 and
how do we explain that to someone who
doesn't know this opening buy my
chessable course
and you will be
you will be elucidated uh educated on
this variation tell us what you can bar
uh rookie two is of course a move that
has been played many times but rookie
one by far in that position was the most
popular move instead of the move rookie
to but let's take a look at the current
position after the move rookie eight um
so C3 C3 makes a lot of sense because
you want to really shut down the
diagonal for the bishop and now Knight
F5 plate and
we have Rook rookie 8 capture Queen
takes C8 and Knight D2 one thing I see
here that I like for white here is just
the fact that this bishop is just
absolutely doing nothing here on F6 and
it's not so clear to see where is the
Knight gonna go to try to put pressure
sometimes they play the move Knight H4
here try to put some pressure on G2 or
also perhaps to provoke the move F3 here
so here Lebon has few options you can
play the move D6 which you just did that
and here let's say nvl plays the move
Bishop D3 attack in the Knight Knight H4
Knight H4 yeah and there is a move
Bishop G3 here
wow and if you capture the pawn on G2
Queen G4 will lead to some very
complicated variations and also it's
hard to see how the Knight is going to
come back into the game but again it's
it's this is not so clear there is a
move H5 in this position so most likely
Levon is not going to allow this uh so
let's see here what else what else he
can try to do here another option is
just to try to get some space here play
the move A4 with idea 5 very positional
and just keep the bishop here on F1 for
now so very solid for both players but
perhaps white is slightly better because
of this c3d4 structure just neutralizing
the bishop on F6 looks like we have our
first thing in the game as MBL uh just
stopping here after the move D7 D6
that's not an easy move to play Bishop
to
D3 Knight to H4 Bishop G3 take my phone
we didn't see it Queen C2 in fact was
mvl's Choice very sensible to killing
the night instantly came the move G7 G6
and now once again the Knight is kind of
compelled to leave in this case he
wasn't attracted to Knight H4 Knight to
D7 but wait a minute now we've got the
tempo Knight E4 Rook E1
feels like some momentum on white side
yes it feels like but it looks like
black is just controlling all the
important squares here and he wants to
now bring his Rook into the game as well
a very small Edge but again hard to see
how to continue here if we can somehow
establish a grip on F6 that would be
nice but it's very very difficult to do
is now H3 is played okay just stopping
any suggestions
a very logical move right bring the Rook
into the game and um
again it's all about the dark squares
here if we can do something so let's try
to move Queen D2 here looks quite equal
right it does it does it's like a very
balanced Berlin suddenly and after
Knight H5 it looks like black is just
absolutely fine just that we switch to
Wesley Geary game all right
well before we do that well let's go to
Warsaw and just see what the what the
view from the capital uh polish city is
like uh over to you Christian
thanks yes sir the view from the capital
but also with a very special guest we
have Gary in the house Gary you've made
the first move for a magnum spot I have
to say Magnus is not really in great
shape today no the the game where I made
the first movie won
I'm not responsible for the rest yes
that's it you know it's all downhill
from there yes uh yeah it's
some not um not very impressive not very
impressive since it's let's say the game
this game is shaky yeah so it's the I
don't know why yes but how do you
because you know it's very difficult to
turn it around
um but how do you do it when you have
a slow start in a blitz tournament
using my memory I don't know that
definitely Magnus Magnus should know
better than I do I still think that's
that's where we haven't seen the rest of
Magnus but
as of now it's um yeah it's odd so is it
about the confidence is it about the
preparation what do you think is lacking
in the first three rounds
Blitz is not so much about preparation I
think it's more it's more about more
about confidence and definitely is
confidence
is not what it used to be so obviously
and I'm but with Magnus you you should
always expect you know
something to happen he can always turn
it around
um it's uh versus Magnus
Rook on D5 you know that's this earlier
oh yeah here yeah why not Rook D5 maybe
even go Rook D5 yeah that's the best
move in the position oh my goodness
she does this yeah oh no that's that's
free
I think 395 Bishop is three and then a
force you've come on yeah such a
comfortable position yeah
yeah amazing they may not go for it how
do we assess this one
yeah it's a probably it's equal now
because he just see The Rook C6 Rook A6
yes it's the the problem is that's the
it's the uh yeah
um
the problem is this is you go to Obi-Wan
you prevent The Rook from getting to a
file
so it's a bit tricky now or maybe you
started with Rook C6 now do you still
have the opportunity to go Rook D5 at
any point
it's not because
yeah okay he just did that yeah
um
still the same I would probably down
distance
but that's that's that's why I thought
you know Magnus had to do it more just
you know it's here yeah it's a rook D1 I
would have played Rook C6 immediately
first yeah because of through the 188
would be one
I have King C7 yes
yes
and you're not worried about the king
side no but it's dead then then a 40K 60
you can know the long Bishop D1 so
that's why yeah that's a very good point
yeah yeah exactly yes so that's the
um
uh small detail but definitely makes a
big difference in this one that's a game
this is the game yeah yeah that's
similar A4 you see that's the yeah okay
it's going to try by the way how are we
doing all the time 135 against it should
be a draw yeah
but
but he does want to make it wrong no he
needs some victories right he's a
victory three and a half points well he
is maybe dreaming about I don't know how
he
comes even if he's pawn it ends up on H4
which is not you know automatic that's
what he has in mind now H5 H4 yeah
that's it to block so let's say we make
some moves H5 H4 but then then this is
totally paralyzed I still don't see how
you can you can make progress but you
know maybe b4p6
B6 B7 yes
slowly but paralyzing this this year
first yeah so that's the key and he's
going for it yeah yeah
of course H5 so I guess he played Bishop
to C2 so that Rook D1 Rook D5 Bishop
Bishop E6 Bishop B6 you don't want to go
Loop D5 now because that's not good
while he played yes Bishop B6
wow
rugby one and now B6
only chance I didn't play for something
it would be six
problems with B6 you know
maybe he plays H4 now after B6 H4
not Rook H1 just star Stars just to take
one yeah this created H3 Maybe
this is what Magnus also wants to see
just something balance
take some chances
but he understands how dangerous B6
because
Rook on A6
it takes time for Rook to come back yeah
I mean in theory if nothing happens The
Rook B6 now let's see in The Stance this
is basically a drop
but he just definitely paralyzes he
spawns there so is this H4 but I see no
basically maybe you can bring the king
somehow to A5 but then I bring the king
okay exactly yes yeah yeah this is over
yeah should we move to a different one
let's see maybe we have some more oh my
goodness what
this is uh Wesley versus Geary
Gary's last move was Rook to see what
takes tasty one look uh he took
something what is he okay
yeah it's winning yeah
no no that was that's what we have
that's it Ah that's it it's over shake a
fence
yeah he did he did something very
spectacular he's definitely uh Bogdan
might be getting his first Victory
um in the blitz portion actually perhaps
against Richie
and by the way we're all the time
well I broke down with his usual seven
seconds again
good enough
Bishop C4 okay
it's not that easy anymore right
baby G5 I think he might have missed
this one
made that move with two seconds Bishop
D2
can I go H5 each one
that's what you'll do now
thank you foreign
two okay
Bishop D5 probably has to be which Bay
eight
Magnus did draw his game against
voitashek nothing unexpected
Bishop B1 good move
perhaps a move missed by rapport
Duda is still playing but right now Rook
F6 yes
horse the trade but that's not good news
that's bad news yes now
A6 A7 and Bogdan is feeling it
you still don't have absolutely any
counter players black
F3 we exchange that King F4
A7
I think we're going to see a resignation
yep resignation wow
big victory for the young Romanian and
the last game pending is uh Duda yeah
draw
the draw
seems like a
like a bedroom bedroom
that's the best way to put it now it's
just
wow
chenko is still flying is there a way to
to do anything here no G5 at some point
no just it doesn't matter it's the G5
you always stay with the pawn
it's over
okay
and they're looking at each other Shake
of hands draw
exciting chess so hard rule this was
always exciting yeah what can I say it
was always exciting yeah so but by the
new world it's it's I mean it's a good
tournament and it's it's what makes me
feel really good is that the the
granches to concept
just proved it's um it's
um
usefulness yeah and it establishes place
in the in the world of Chess and we had
some ups and downs but now we're on a
solid path to expand uh our reach so
it's uh oh it's always um uh
um
solid to have two uh to foundations
which is One Foundation but it's it's
two you may say it's two two legs in
America and in Europe and um actually
make us suggestion that some may could
find a bit far-fetching uh spoke to the
Polish organizers we're very proud some
of the some of the minor sponsors of the
event who joined to us a little bit but
locals uh companies
they're very impressed with the event
and I said look it's a somehow it's a
you know you have an interesting um a
reference a reminiscences of geopolitics
so we have
been grantchester the Coalition similar
to the Coalition of willing helping
Ukraine we have America Poland Romania
and Croatia yeah so there's a Hungary
so yeah it's in chess so it's it's uh
again it's it's of course it's a stretch
I understand but still you know we just
as they say in every coincidence there
is element of coincidence and I have to
say Gary a very inspired wild card we
lost the world champion ding one week
before this event but Levon is doing
just an amazing job yeah absolutely it's
just that's that's that's it improves
the old chess uh rule that you know
always watch the Players and invite the
last minute
no chance to prepare but definitely
bringing his hunger to this that's a
rabbit and blades and live on this you
know it's a seasoned season fighter so
but but then he plays fresh chess and I
like his game was Dura yeah so this is
F4 these are very this that's like
old-fashioned players yeah some
few the romance of 90 cents which is one
more question uh for you Gary before we
throw it back to the studio uh when
you're getting ready to make the move
for Magnus Magnus wasn't there and
Wesley told you come to my boss no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no he said take mad Lucy plays
thank you very much for joining us
appreciate it guys back to you in the
studio you uh Christian and thank you
Gary uh let's take a look at the
standings after four very of them for
Blitz rounds all right we have
a point
closely following Yankers of Duty just
half Point behind and now MPL is in
clear third right creeping up and Wesley
in the fourth place Magnus is still in
the fifth place and our parents coming
up for round five do the honors we have
Carlson again
Bradford against white hashik giridiak
an All-American matchup Iranian so
that's gotta be our Marquee matchup and
dude I'm feel we got Plan B absolutely
and bar jumped in as uh well the blitz
is living up to every expectation we had
absolutely and nakira Chef jenko is
known to be a blitz specialist and it's
been pretty impressive here with two out
of three stars and he actually he could
have win his third game here in this
position against Duda he has a very nice
Advantage pair of the Bishops and but he
had to play just the natural good move
in this position here here he played the
move E4 and the position became
complicated and that being a joy at end
but if you just play the move Rook fd1
simply attacking the pawn and if if you
play the move E6 if you cast so you're
just slightly worse after Bishop D5
takes Rook D5 because white will have a
control of the C file and also Rook on
D5 is very active so the natural move E6
just to protect the pawn will be a big
problem for black because now the move
Bishop C7 comes in and now if you play
the move Queen B7 after Bishop D6 your
king gets stuck in the middle of the
board and again there are ideas with E4
to open up the position so this would
have been actually very strong for him
to play but instead he played a move
here E4 and last most of his Advantage
after that and it became a draw at the
end
our commercial break as around five
coming up very shortly we'll see you on
the other side see you soon
[Music]
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
[Music]
chess and St Louis is back with nine
major tournaments throughout the year
for the first time since 2020 the Cairns
cup is Back featuring the world's best
female chess players competing for a 180
000 prize fund beginning June 3rd
seasonal Classic Events are back the
summer chess classic August 2nd followed
up with the St Louis Norm Invitational
and the winter chess classic wraps up
the year in December September brings
back everyone's favorite chess night
Alex where some of the world's best
don't even know what's coming and
compete for a 150 000 prize fund 30
players across three Fields come
together in St Louis for the U.S juniors
girls and Senior championships starting
July 15th in partnership with U.S chess
the best in the U.S fight to be the
nation's best and a four hundred
thousand dollar prize fund in October as
the U.S and U.S women's championships
takes place in the chess capital of
America a year full of action-packed
chess is just getting started all
broadcasts are available on our St Louis
chess club YouTube and twitch.tv
channels
[Music]
thank you foreign
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
with 14 and a half points it's a slim
lead though yes only half Point behind
yeah Christoph Duda who's not doing so
well one out of four in the blitz but
mvl's doing great in the blitz he had
two and a half today so he's in the
clear third now and Wesley so down to
the fourth now after a loss against the
niche and Magnus still in the fifth
place and tell us about the pairings
coming up for this round five which is
about to begin grab Carlton again
rapper the way tashek giri diac and then
All-American matchup irony and so that's
got to be our Marquee matchup right
there that Lavon game do that again Plan
B we've got it
uh boy I tell you the first four rounds
have been exciting and that game that
honey scary just pulled off against
Wesley I mean that looks like maybe the
brilliancy of the tournament uh uh VAR
that was really outstanding for a Blitz
game I would be very proud to put that
in uh my best games of Chess absolutely
and giri is playing really well in 1950
if he had won that game against Anvil he
would have been three and a half out of
four in a blitz section so he I think
he's in picking up his form yeah sir
absolutely And he as you say he was
winning that game in three and a half
out of four is just the type of start he
needs he had such a bad rapid showing
but again we are going to focus on the
vulneronian who does have a half point
lead clear first Wesley so slip but you
know Wesley can play really great too I
mean you saw what he did against Magnus
uh to start the show off earlier and
Lavon
uh a wild card player in general
enjoying his opportunity
playing the Joko piano
game right yes me Italian
oh no diet
moves Knight C3 quite off the beat
pardon me quite off the Beaten Track
there of Art
yes uh D3 or rookie one are more popular
Knight C3 still played Knight A4
inviting Knight takes E4 I'm assuming
Bishop D5 Knight takes E4 why can't I
take a peschke actually you can take
that's the top move in the position
Knight takes C4 D3
and here you have two options you can go
back on F6 but then after that you're
slightly worse after Knight takes C5 D
takes C5 rookie one you're gonna have
some problems with the E5 Pawn in this
position uh or you can if you don't want
to go back to F6 you can play the move
uh Knight takes F2
in this position
and if you take Rook F2 actually this is
a bad position for for white here
because
two good Pawns in exchange and black is
better here but looks like there is an
idea here there is a move Queen E2 here
wow and now with the idea to eliminate
the bishop with Knight C5 and then only
pick up the Knight so there is Knight D3
this line continues I wonder if they
won't probably Analyze This Knight takes
C5
Knight takes C5 and there is the move
Knight G5 very complicated position even
here position is not clear guys there's
a move F5 but uh sorry I just gotta
interrupt you because the players have
really gone and completely different
direction yeah and uh the current
position I want to ask you is it still
Theory or did they deviate where was the
name no moves in my database in the
current position I will go back just to
see where the new moves was but uh right
right here I think the move
H6 was the new move in this position I
see yeah we do have G4 on the board
Bishop G6 and it's always at the tension
of having
um push the pawn Shield forward or you
know the weakness of the white king
versus the I want to say offside passive
Bishop how to judge that that's really
real really hard nice stage two nice
little surprising night H4 looked very
logical much more compelling definitely
90 okay but uh a single idea I want to
play F2 F4 potentially
if I can play Rook takes F6 and make
sure that Bishop is a prisoner for the
rest of the game I'm very happy to
sacrifice the exchange of those
positions so F2 F4 is on White's agenda
uh VAR how is black supposed to cross
White's plans actually black should play
a very active move in this position
Queen A2 Queen eight that's a logical
move activating the queen putting
pressure on B3 and also keep an eye on
the B2 pawn and if you play the move F4
there it takes F6 see like he can take
Bishop 4 here but in that line you
cannot take with the bishop because you
would drop the B2 Pawn you're right the
queen yeah just to keep the bishop under
arrest but now Bishop takes F4 there's a
bishop takes H6 sighting we see the
Knight go back to D7 and Knight F3 feels
like white has the Freer game and maybe
this bishop is in danger being offsides
I don't know I think if black queen
comes back now Queen d8 I didn't want to
allow Knight H4 that was my was my idea
doing okay
I don't know I've got a hook here I'm
still thinking that Queen D2 and Bishop
takes H6 could be on the agenda Knight
D4 that attack might backfire
white king is also quite weak actually
weaker than black skin at the moment so
yes it's true my favorite move to 4g2 is
not uh permitted uh Queen back to d8 you
wanted to say that you'd like that to
move move ago stop ignite H4 and if
white plays Knight out of five I think
black can just take it
yeah
funnily enough I would be reluctant to
play Knight F5
um wow uh Knight C5 okay this Knight's
going to E6
true but I like what you said about just
taking that night off the board I would
have seen this piece as a as a danger
piece
but uh night coming back to E6 uh VAR
feels like
black is stabilized nicely yeah black is
fine here one of the ideas of the Knight
C5 is if you play the move B4 he wants
to put the Knight only six which will
give him good protection around G7 and
also he's getting ready to play the move
D5
right which is the the breakout move
that black always aspires to in these
types of structures after all the Rook
is on E file he would love to see an
open e-file so d65 on Black's agenda B4
96 as advertised queen of three
that does put a little bit of a kibosh
on D5 here I would be tempted just to
trade everybody and then take on a four
precisely and follow it up with Queen G5
yeah I'm just very very happy or
comfortable I would say uh here
and d65
again he's thinking you take my Pawn
I'll take your bishop and I'll recapture
and I'm happy camper okay
yes but it's it's permitted but people
want to that's the thing it's like the
pawn could be artificially isolated
after E5 I would play it probably play
D4 and not to let you play d3d4 if I
will and it's possible that the pawn on
E5 could become a liability
but yeah uh from White's point of view
how does he keep the game alive of our
yeah I like that your suggestion of
deforge after the move E5 and I think
black is actually maybe even a little
bit better in that position so now after
the move D5 uh E5 he has to go for it if
he doesn't he took he took
so he is inviting Bishop takes F5 as
well as Knight takes up four corner for
Queen takes D5 which is which is the
initial intention you you regain the
pawn but more importantly this Rook is
looking to uh set up an immediate
counter-attack with rookie two Pawn on
D3 saying and white plots are quite weak
a couple of different weak pawns this
did not pan out I guess okay too right
now yeah this did not pan out whatsoever
for Lavon and I think he would be very
happy to make a draw yeah to make a draw
rookie to Rook F2 and a repetition he'd
be very happy to get out of Dodge
and by the way uh while we'll stay with
this game we do get uh reports that
Maggie Magnus
are both winning uh we'll stay with us
the move C7 C6 just getting out of any
potentials of Queen takes C7 rookie two
is not going away I don't know uh and
that's it I'm just not liking White's
position now why it has to be very
careful very careful things could easily
easily go wrong and LeBron has one
minute less than Wesley so that's a fact
Knight G3 just covering a business
Square on the e-file I didn't want to
see The Rook landing on E2 but now we
see a very very good Bishop which is
doing a great job defending F7 defending
the king and basically with everything
well defended on the king side
black can go For Broke on the queen side
I love this move Queen B3 and Black's
Queen and Bishop can use the white
squares to move around whatever Wesley
places to exactly 53 C4 clock time's a
factor Levon has made it in 10 seconds
and Wesley has two minutes so twice as
much time for Wesley good position for
Wesley good position on the clock as
well B5 just fixing
the structure and VAR what's your take
uh realistic chances of winning but
because
lavon's position is solid very solid and
there are no no really weaknesses uh for
for Levon here now he played the movie
H4 it shows that he is still ambitious I
guess but this move could backfire
because now he has weakened the G4 uh he
could have just simply put the King on H
to put the Rook on F2 and just see how
white black is going to try to pick up
the position yeah but with the clock
situation up definitely like Wesley's
chances right now but
um I'm not sure what is this H4 move
gonna do now because it seems like now
G4 Pawn is weak and you don't really
want to play G5 Here and Now Wesley is
trying to improve his Bishop yeah the
bishop could either come to E6 tickling
G4 or even the rather dominant Square D5
um I was also looking a queen E6
immediately just a moment ago just
asking why you know go ahead tell me
what you're doing about G4 we do have
Bishop S7 Rook F2 and uh your team now
H4 was really surprising yeah I guess
Lavon has uh
breaking news Richie recovered and won
his game again who did he be white
and Magnus has won his game and who did
that
so Magnus is uh beating up the youngster
uh Queen to D5 Queen uh dropped back do
you think Levon has ideas to still
attack Black's King with G5 at some
point no question about it I'm not a I'm
not a big fan of the last few moves by
Wesleyan Queen for 19 F5 rookie one
looks scary
yeah that's uh well rookie E4 invites
Queen B a check no Queen B8 Queen f8
what what queen V8 king queen f8
I want to mate you
um they told me that Checkmate is ends
the game Rook G4 oh that's a good
defense
sorry Brooke thanks to you thank you
good morning a lot of time maybe he
didn't say it either because he came
down to five seconds whoa he's playing
on five seconds now and his position
looks very uncomfortable it sure does he
there was a mate on H1 Rook G2 looks a
little awkward uh
if black just plays Queen E4 now what is
White's next move
uh oh I see Bishop D5 I
Queen E4 with the idea Bishop D5 and
Wesley
he missed it
he missed it well that's the course of
time trouble it's very hard to find the
accurate moves but the watch is picking
up pawns on the quinces
what is Rook E2 what is H5 this is
really scary what a great move H5 uh oh
and Lavon has no time Levon is just
losing on time I think Wesley's winning
now
H5 was brilliant
Checkmate is coming oh no Queen E2 and
Who's Laughing frogging who uh Wesley
quick recovery after that loss whoa
let's jump to the mvl game is it still
ongoing uh
five seconds against ten but uh Duda is
up a pawn in an end game Bishop versus
knight so looking good for dinner it was
super he just has to play Fast
don't lose on time because we saw mvl
miraculously win a lost position against
Danish
and I'm told that Anish who was winning
against the arc earlier let it slip and
dioc
won the game won the game oh my gosh
what is happening with my my pigs I have
no idea no I think we don't have a
single draw in this round
all the size of games and dudas seems to
be yep
wow stopping mvl streak Duda was not
doing well I think he had one and a half
or one one out of four here one out of
four coming into this and he just beat
and a very informed MBL what around
did you say all games all games were
indecisive wow
incredible uh over to you bar just get
us caught up on what just happened
because that was
that was some action yeah
yeah I really like this game by a ritual
report he had a good position throughout
the game and the Finishing Touch was
very nice as well guys the last one was
Rook takes C8 I will go back to show you
so in this position he's already doing
really really well winning end game but
he finished it up with a very nice Rook
take C8 winning the Knight now takes
back and D7 forking the Rooks and uh in
this position voitashek resigned here
and let's take a look at another game
um here we have
this game here I think I thought it was
just equal end game for for a long time
out of the opening but somehow the
bishop in this position is better than
Knight here and the weakness on H7
engine is showing is is about equal here
but I find it easier to play with the
white pieces because you have a plan of
playing H4 H5 and then F4 and that's
exactly how uh Duda improved his
position eventually exchanged Rooks and
won this end game even though it looks
equal but I think Bishop is slightly
better than Knight in this position and
he managed to convert this very slightly
better end game into an important win
here
thank you VAR and after this very
eventful round five tell us about the
standings
oh no I think they're update in the
standing so it's so much change
and Wesley bouncing that right uh an
Iranian wasn't so lit I think he pushed
too far with the H4 yeah that was an
overreach yeah if you had more time on
the clock he would have never lost that
position but time trouble
well let's jump over to warsa and get uh
the view of what's happening over there
Christian
some very interesting games indeed and
uh spectacularly bugged down the act
with back-to-back victories he beat the
rich report in the previous round and
now another huge Victory against the
struggling
like casparov was saying let's take a
look at what's happening in uh this one
we have a typical Karo Khan on the board
92 H6 91 and now we see this dance for
the G5 Square Knight to E1 saying that
I'm going to go to D3 and potentially to
F4 black is saying okay I'm going to go
H5 I'm going to go Knight to H6 and
that's how I'm going to develop my
pieces but once you play H5 G5 square is
weak once again so I jump with the other
Knight to F3 so let's take a look at
what happened after this massive
exchanges on H6 and F5 the problem is
you're creating new weaknesses and that
pawn on F5 If you defend it with G6 The
Rook on H6 is just going to be stranded
completely out of uh play and at some
point I'm going to go E6 this is not
looking good maybe I can even go E6
right now sacrifice upon you take take
it I go Knight d395 this is looking
marvelous for white he played the move
F4 but you still have a lot of
weaknesses H5
giri was taking over and by the way he
was taking over on time as well two
minutes 22 seconds for him 28 seconds
for bogda typical of course Knight to F4
Queen to D7 big opportunity right now
for Anish he played the move E6 but this
was just not a good Pawn sacrifice what
he had to do is in fact leave the queen
on pre on F5 take on H5 with the Knight
you take it Knight G7 I'm going to
recapture it back and then I'm going to
take the bishop only 7 and The Pawn on
H4 is going to be weak this would have
been a great transition
he didn't see it and actually I'm not
100 sure let's see how much time he
spent he did spend more than a minute at
this point wow and he did not finite he
was really calculating this E6 get the
Knight to E5 try to get the Checkmate
and Bogdan was playing with four seconds
for the remainder of the game he played
with four seconds and he defended
absolutely incredible
um in the end game it felt for a second
that may be honest she's getting back on
if she's trying to outplay his young
opponent but Anish is the one with the
weaknesses that pawn on A2 is a huge
weakness the pawn on A3 is not a
liability for black it's a huge weapon
because if you lose that's why the pawn
on A2 the game is over yeah I'm going to
quit and you also have the King which is
not that safe very nice play by Bogdan
and at this point after Knight to C5
this was a critical mistake after Knight
takes C5 I believe this was perhaps the
last move we see detect C5 but I think
he didn't make this move with enough
time on the clock I believe he flagged
in this position nevertheless the game
is more or less objectively winning for
black after the move Rook to H3 so even
if the game would have continued most
likely Bogdan would have won it's all
about getting to that pawn on A2 Rook to
E3 this is a bad end game for uh White I
take take King A6 King B5 King C4 and
the King Justice very nice game yes yes
but also Anish also missed some
opportunities right yeah so I checked
the game between Magnus Carson and
against actually this was example of the
game when you do this opposite castling
and you just simply lose because your
attack doesn't work right so I'm
actually Magnus just literally killed
poor kiril I mean I'm really playing the
dragon okay I mean he's asking for it
actually is really asking he was asking
for it when he got it yes so but but
nevertheless he had some chances you
know but here I mean Magnus who just
simply went G4 I'll show you this one on
G4 you play against number one in the
world and he plays you for he wants to
give a Checkmate it's not an easy
situation and then after before actually
here kiril made a crucial mistake he
could have tried to play something like
who did like more creatively so now if
you take this Knight black has this
opportunity you know this to use this
pin so actually what I understood that
in this position what was the most
important piece was this Knight on F6 so
this move Knight C6 instead of Rook d8
allowed actually
um why to take this bishop or this
Knight only F6 and then that's it I mean
the position just collapses simply um
you are right but at the same time time
you know how to push H5 so when you take
the Knight just everything is open after
that all the files so 95 you also
exchange couple of pieces and after 94
he just simply
um took the pawn on G4 I mean and then
simply played like H5 there were some
chances maybe black could have tried to
take on C2 but you can understand I mean
there are some other issues here
let's say if the Rook takes then Rook D4
most probably will come so you lose a
piece like whatever so it was not really
possible so at this moment the position
suddenly became completely lost and of
course couldn't do anything with this
white simply he tried a little bit he
tried to push the pods and if I've tried
to open some files but you can see that
it's just game it's Amazon after a
couple of moves I mean what just simply
played Queen H2 and there is no way how
to defend against this checklist maybe
you're a few tempe's behind right just
an incredible incredible game and an
important victory for Magnus because
he's struggling in this event he needs
some victories to be able to catch up
with the leaders potentially guys so a
lot of fun exciting chess here in Poland
back to Union Studio
the iconic images that was going to stay
with us for the rest of this event is
this one right here as the fans are
besieging the world's number one
classical radio player Magnus Carlson
who is obliging yes and that's when I
saw him and the fans are so so happy to
be here the little boys somehow you know
standing on somebody's shoulders to get
in there as we take a look at our
standings uh after five rounds very
exciting Blitz actually
and um switched I guess once again now
to do this half Point ahead live on
and uh Wesley Wesley's in the third
place he came back with a win and wheels
in the fourth place and Magnus still in
fifth but getting closer and closer yeah
but dude is victory over MBL is not only
that he leap her out to move on he kind
of pushed down the competitor as the
jockeying for first place is really
intense tell us about the pairings
coming up for this round six I had
exciting parents uh chefchenko and VL
that's gotta be our Marquee match up
there as the fight for purse is so
intense all right dick against aronia
boy Tasha kigiri and Carlson against
Rapport that's a good plan B
as we get to take a very short break and
we'll see on the other side for round
six of Blitz don't go anywhere foreign
chess tour is back for its eighth trip
around the world inspired by former
world champion Gary Kasparov the
grantchester hosts the top players to
compete for top prizes eight of the
world's best joint tournament wild cards
and travel to four different countries
to fight for a 1.4 million dollar prize
fund the tour kicks off in Bucharest
Romania for the superbet chess classic
then things speed up as we move to
Warsaw Poland and Zagreb Croatia for the
first two rapid and Blitz events the
tour then makes its way to St Louis
Missouri for the final two events we're
back in November for the St Louis rapid
and Blitz and the illustrious sinkfield
cup when points are up for grabs the
best players show up who will be crowned
the new Champion find out when the grand
chess tour returns
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
meet me at the beauty the beauty in
Forest Park the muni's premier season
bursting with comedies romance and Magic
Begins June 12th with the muni premiere
of beautiful the Carole King musical
the Epic summer continues with Disney's
Beauty and the Beast chess West Side
Story Little Shop of Horrors rent and
sister
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back everyone to the superbet
rapid and Blitz we have after five
rounds of Blitz the following standing
all right dude I was back in the lid
with a half Point ahead from 11 of
Iranian quickly following closely close
and obviously saw in the third place MBL
in the fourth and Magnus still in the
fifth place exactly because
it tightened it up a little it was three
points out of personalities only two
it's all to play for about the pairings
for this round six is going to decide a
lot chefchenko mvl so against Duda you
have me right there so it gets due to
our Marquee matchup as the fight for
first is intense Dia caronium
and Carlson report we've got a plan B
Magnus and Richie are
very exciting now please tell me VAR
that the game between Wesley and Duda is
not going to be a pet rock
yes just a lie to me if you have to I
think there's a chance maybe dude that
will play something more active but the
one thing I noticed nobody is doing
really really great in a blitz portion
so far guys the best score is three out
of five basically plus one is the best
score in a blitz portion so far so we
don't have anybody with plus three or
something so that just shows they're
just beating each other up you know
somebody wins the next round he loses so
a lot of back and forth action we see
but for me I mean I'm suffering terribly
alongside our Niche because a niche is
playing great he's getting winning
positions and then he's proceeding to
blunder them away uh which you know is
not you know the formula for success but
he he is a a factor in this first round
first day of Blitz I mean because he
could have he could be the guy scoring
four or even four and a half out of five
from the positions he's had spoiling
yeah uh tournaments as they are underway
oh no oh no
once again
okay okay an Italian not Berlin either
so nice it's an achievement okay good
good good good early Castle so every
player lost at least one game today
correct it seems that way
yes yes because mvl
Wesleyan everyone lost
yeah everyone's got dinged
which is kind of what you expect these
guys are monsters and the idea that uh
they're not going to inflict a loss on
you well that's just very very uh
not going to happen Bishop B5 I'm
assuming that we are still in the bowels
of theory here of art yes we are in
theory but not so many games played only
five games in my database and we have
been seeing this idea A5 a lot actually
in this tournament you know and I think
we also saw in the previous term in
Romania as well this idea just to try to
prevent B4 whites from Gaining space on
the queen side
okay so Bishop B5 made room for the
night but Wesley's pardon me
um yes it is Wesley right yeah yeah
Wesley's rookie one indicates that maybe
he's looking for Knight F1 Knight G3
yeah yeah slow improvements I thought
the move Bishop B5 wasn't designed to
allow Knight C4 why did Bishop B5 help
I think he wants to exchange the wide
squared Bishop so he can get his Knight
out of five easy you know you waited for
eviction yes I thought the bishop was
good on C4 why did he need to exchange
lights or admission it will remain a
mystery but you were saying Queen takes
D7 Knight G3 on on and then maybe Knight
H4 and Knight of five okay okay I can I
can get behind that but then if I'm
gonna play Knight H4 I'm thinking to
myself I'd sure like to have a light
squared Bishop wouldn't want to
voluntarily Trade It Off
uh rookie eight maybe he wants to play
D4 yes and he did yeah D4 I like that
the SEC the classical Central pandu
putting pressure on E5 and
uh Bishop E3 sure looks like a
Queen detail whites ever so marginally
better VAR in uh the Wesley so do they
game I I'm thinking I prefer white I
just don't know by how much yeah so
white is slightly better here and I
think one of the main ideas is just you
know you can put a knight on F5 at some
point and black doesn't have that light
Square Bishop to try to remove you at
some point but in if you look at the
bishop only three this bishop is
actually doing a good job defending D4
and also taking care of the F4 square at
some point if black jumps in Knight F4
he can simply take it very very small
Advantage here for white so the A4 is
just played so let's take a look what
Wesley can do here so he just responded
with the move Queen C2 very logical move
protecting the E4 pawn and now getting
ready to play the move Rook 81. Queen C6
Now by Duda pulling pressure on e4 here
and I think uh yeah Rook 81 so and at
some point white is getting close to
play this move Knight F5 to put pressure
on G7 here slightly better position uh
for white the best move here is to take
on D4 to try to exchange some pounds
because you cannot take back with the
pawn because the queen on C2 is pinned
so you're gonna have to take back with
the Knight on D4 and then you can play
the move Queen C4 here so here I think
black is just only very slightly better
sorry black is only slightly better or
white white is only slightly excited I
mean for me I thought that white was
slightly better but I I okay very cool
very cool I'm not expecting e takes D4
B5 looks like if you play A4 might as
well play B5 right
five
five and if black spots uh changing
anything in the center
what is exactly what's playing I really
want to play Queen C1 and I want it
smack you on uh H6 uh
I don't know if if you play B5 and I
play D5 for example just putting a
question uh to you and by the way B5 on
the board uh D5 where are you going to
put your queen uh Queen side or in the
center you're going to retreat to
descent I could do both because both
have their processes yeah
because I do I am thinking if your queen
goes well by the way rooked Rook to see
one and dude was already is uh has a
half the time of Wesley's yes three
minutes against four minutes Wesley is
remarkably quick he's very consistent
like mvl he oftentimes builds up a a
Time advantage that he uses extremely
well Bishop B6 just marking time uh VAR
and asking why what are you doing Queen
D3 both players uh probing but not
necessarily Landing blows C4 now
yes C4 is one idea he could have played
the move D5 instead of Queen D3 and just
then follow it up with the move C4 I
liked uh I like that because I like the
pressure I like the space
um Rook B8 to my mind that invites the
move B3 because I'm thinking that the
Rook on A8 Disco urge me from playing B3
but now that you've moved your Rook off
the a file I personally would find the
move B3 attractive as I would find the
move B4 is attractive a rookie E2 Rook
E2 again marking time to what purpose
I'm not sure
Queen
and this Knight of four not good that
exchange four okay well that's very much
yeah we do have in between mode D5 Maybe
somewhere yeah it's necessary otherwise
I would lose a pawn right so Knight F4
is very forcing for yes Knight F4 the
bishop takes F4 will be played and he's
coming back Knight F5 for white
uh because there is a 97 check in case
of uh capturing
so do I have to include D5 or immediate
Knight no just immediate Knight F5 and
where is 97 Chuck
I don't think no I'm taken with the
Knight well is this helping helping
myself and then Rook ce1 if you take
with the knife
by the way we do have a result mvl drew
his game against Kerala shevchenko
and Mac was seems to be winning against
Richard Rapport it's a exchange up I see
there Knight takes E4 well we're about
to find out uh and test the waters Rook
C E1 D5 looks obliged yeah D5 is on the
board in 92.
uh again I'm eyeballing this Knight E7
uh play G6 ooh it's giving up H6 smack
that pawn off the board Knight takes H6
check King G7 Knight G4
that looks well first of all I won my
Pawn back I'm very very happy about that
by the way the bishop on B6 in danger of
becoming a septic
Bishop a very passive Bishop
I like that Wesley Wesley in the
driver's seat uh VAR actually Duda needs
to play A3 if he finds this move he's
going to be fine here A3 yes
try to create some uh Contra play on a
queen side A3 that is Lands just in time
five because the night on e4 he's done
the F5 move A3 did look very interesting
okay he's invited Knight E5 and he's
gonna no he didn't sacrifice an exchange
so
he's missed his opportunity for A3 but
for the moment the Knight is still
plugging up the e-file Knight is on e4
yes he actually could have taken only
five instead of Queen D6 GE then played
the move A3 again exactly just to get
some Contra play but uh it's still okay
here at this position just very only
like a very slight Advantage for white
here that Knight only four is extremely
strong and it's just very well supported
by the dnf pawns so I still have an
advantage because Wesley dropped back
with the knight from E5 yeah and do that
quickly played C5 and now looks like his
pieces are improving very quickly okay I
still want to get in this move A2 A3 and
if I can get an A3 and Knight D4 I feel
like I still have an advantage but
you're right at the same time I do feel
like something is Slipped Away a bit
this Knight on e4 is very very
bothersome but I think A3 is important I
don't want to see black playing the move
A4
okay Wesley has put the kibosh on both
ideas of B4 as well as A3
at this moment you may call it for as
far who's going to win
well guess what the evaluation is guys
don't say it clean V6 tickling F2 Knight
is dropping on D4 so Wesley is hoping
hoping that he'll be able to get in an
F3 at a moment Duda down to 20 seconds
and now B4 is a good idea he just played
it before talk about tactically alert
wow is very nice I thought
I wanted to stop that just one move
before Knight D2 to F3 and then you you
your life would have been good
now he's taken on B4 taken on D4 he'll
win his Pawn back Queen takes B4 but
Knight F3
to E5
but and it's all about the clock as well
those night would be better right F3 or
even Knight B1 could be played here as
well just try to get the Knight on C3 I
love Knight F3 because I'm thinking in
my Minds I I want to play 95 and queen
A6 and remind you that the G6 Pawn is
playing with just five seconds on the
clock because of the clock times but
also because of the vulnerable King
position I want to retain Queens I want
to play Queen D1 and retain Queens those
of you who want to play 95 I I
appreciate that too because there are
some weak Pawn on F4 right the in the
end game white can have an advantage
because A4 F4 exactly could be and then
I could play F3 so 95 is beginning to
look even more but I like your move
Queen D1 is very tempting 95 comes with
a tempo right and again the black king a
little bit more vulnerable
uh 50 seconds for Wesley and eight
seconds for Duda eight seconds for Duda
wow and he did retain the Queens with
Queen D1 quickly came Rook C8 95. and
queen he's chasing the White Queen he's
hunting it down should I play Knight D3
and would you consider Queen A1 just to
avoid that I would but it's too passive
on anyone oh he played it he played it
and wow
the queen I I unders how do you get the
queen to E7 though Rook to C1 okay I get
this queen C7 check what what oh first
rank problems
Rook D1 oh King H2 this is necessary two
and he's done it prophylaxis moves sorry
again clock time Wesley has 20 seconds
and Duda
wow just made uh with one second on his
clock he made his move with one second
and he's invited Rook C7 check
but he didn't three
yeah this game's hitting up Queen C1 get
your queen back into the game
Wesleyan right yes yes and he's done it
oh he's invited Queen takes F4
Queen B8 perhaps yes he's done that too
was this down to five seconds but Knight
E5 and Rook takes each coins come off no
I thought Knight takes Knight E5 and
Rook takes E4 was on White's agenda wait
now is now black better because I have
the a pawn you certainly do that's a
Monster Pawn what has Wesley done he's
transposed into a losing ending A2 it
might not be losing but black does look
better
wow
by the way uh Lavon don't forget our
wild card
against dick and by the way Knight C3
crazy game
Wesley holding I'm not sure Wesley's
holding
me
and giri also won his oh a rook D1 he
allowed Rook to D5 check so he got off
the pin that was a terrible move by by
Duda a blunder Wesley's winning now is
he yeah he's threatening Checkmate wow
what a
oh my word uh he's not going to repeat
three times I don't think no just gain
some time and
Bart is a computer don't you dare tell
me Triple zeros no no it's completely
winning it is completely winning but at
the time Wesley the amount of times was
repeating that he might accidentally
by the way Magnus defeated Richard
Rapport very important game and hold on
I mean every time I think that Wesley is
doing something really well some counter
plays being allowed or am I missing no
Knight takes F4 Knight E3 check just
King H3 and life is good by the way G
they just need to play very quickly
wait F3 came off but so did G6 Rook G5
it's two connected paths oh Wesley's
reaching for his King
is he Allowed no he did not allow Knight
takes G3 because it was a king G2 Cheapo
worldwide's winning so
clearly anymore oh Wesley is he
blundered he's made move with one second
on the clock King has to go to G1
come on Wesley what are you doing wow a
draw
what dude
is is slippery as a as an eel it's
amazing unbelievable yeah how did he say
that he was two pawns down Andy was down
under attack and the clock
close the flag in more than once but
here with like a second he's still
stumbling and finally and when he
pressed his clock yeah once it was a
second yeah
by the way that can be so off-putting
you're you're aware of the clock and
your opponent keeps making a move with
one second it's sort of like so
frustrating
bar what's what happened what did we
just witness no it was a crazy back and
forth I think at some point do that was
actually winning also in that end game
but I want to show you the Leones win
because he had a really dominating win
against deck here and I want to bring
that game please attention here and uh
towards the end I just like how he
activated all his pieces here so and uh
so let me go back a little bit and
so right right in this position his his
pieces are actually Brooks are now very
well placed here in just the next few
moves we'll see suddenly all these Rook
is going to come in the first Rank and
it's going to be a dominating win for
level here here he's slightly better
here first he plays the move Rook B6 and
at some point he wants to play Queen F6
as well to bring the queen to F4 Queen
A1 now diac is trying to control the the
first rank here now Queen F6 now
improving by each move he's improving
the piece first he does this rook and
now the queen wants to come to F4 and
now King H1 again if you have to play a
move like this you're not doing that
great here and now Rook severe the other
Rook comes in and now Rook B1 is a very
serious threat here and you don't have a
rookie one as well because the Knight on
D3 is so strong putting pressure and
also controlling the E1 Square so he
played this move Queen F1 but now once
your pieces get pinned like this you're
you're not going to be able to survive
this game 91 and now Levon brought this
other Rook into the game and it's just
completely winning and he won the rook
and the game as well here the other game
I was looking is the game that ended
actually in the draw here we saw a
repetition in this game and was very
complex position but somehow players
just decided to repeat here with Queen
H5 and queen H4 here I think chefchenko
could have definitely played for a win
here he had to just retreat with the
queen but they decided to repeat with
this queen H5 and queen G4 ideas
and let's just refresh our standings
after a very every round's very eventful
I don't even know how to put it anymore
but Lavon now they're sharing the first
place who said
at the end of The Blitz there might be a
tie for first continue please aronians
first Wesley in the clear third and
Magnus sharing fourth place was MPL but
Magnus showing with blitz resulted four
yeah four out of five six four eighty
six and uh let's let's jump to Warsaw
and the perspective
from the chess capital
well speaking of Magnus and his victory
take a look at what happened in this
game between himself and Richie report
we've seen that battle yesterday in the
last rapid game of the day that was so
intense and this one did not disappoint
either let's take a look C4 G6 E4 Bishop
G7 D4 this is what I like about Richie
he's inviting a fight G6 Bishop G7
always especially in uh rapid and Blitz
let's have some fun and this is a benoni
a very typical line of the benoni if you
allow me uh to take with the e-pawn
generally players with the white pieces
do this because it offers them a slight
Advantage but a very long term Advantage
just because of the fact that you have
more space Rook 28 Bishop to E3 and take
a look at this Richard says okay let's
play Rook takes E3 I'm going to
sacrifice The Exchange I'm going to take
advantage of the fact that you're giving
me the dark Square bishop and now the
[__] Pawn G7 is not going to have a
counterpart so this is a typical uh
exchange sacrifice unfortunately for
Richie as we will see in just a second
he did not make great use of it he took
on C3 and I think this was a critical
mistake in my opinion probably he should
just go F4 Bishop to E2 then get the
Knight to E5 and the thing is it's not
so bad not so bad not so bad and
whenever you go and this is what he was
afraid of whenever you go E4 I have
ideas of giving you another Pawn with F4
just to keep uh the control like this
the Knight on E5 you're not going to be
able to touch it you're going to take
another Pawn but Bishop D7 Rook to f8 is
coming I have great control over the
dark squares he took on C3 bad move yeah
[Music]
that was a bit different and uh by the
way at this point after Queen to F6 Rook
to C7 would have been much better just
because of the fact that once you take
take you don't have a good way to defend
the pawn on C4 if you try to do it with
Rook F4 I can jump to D3 and that's
going to put uh enough pressure on you
yeah and the key is that after King to
f8 I can also just go Rook to B1 if I
want Rook to B1 that's going to get my
Rook off the E1 Square you go Rook to C7
to defend it and then I go back no more
night today so you don't take the pawn
but by the way Richie after A4 he was
like I'm I don't want your ball I'm not
sure why I would have taken that pawn on
C4 immediately but he did not and uh
another key moment at this point Rook to
G1 and Magnus decided to transition into
this rookan game maybe from an objective
perspective this was not the right
decision nevertheless I understand it
from a practical perspective you have
this Pawn on D5 such a nice Pawn in in a
Black's position and ready to promote at
any point in this game critical moment
after Rook to H5 if you allow me to play
E4 as white your game is pretty much
over so that's why Richie played the
move E4 very very nice move otherwise
for example if you go Rook to E8 E4 Rook
2 E8 King to E3 and I'll try to take
advantage and get some counter play of
your own via Rook to G8 Rook to F5 yeah
that loses the pawn on uh yes very
unpleasant so it's better to give the
pawn than to lose it like this exactly
and well he's not giving it that's the
thing he's actually not he's defending
it with F5 he found this nice maneuver
King G6 F5 and this is what we had
objectively equal but Magnus found a way
to get some Advantage even in this one
by the way Rook to E2 seems to have been
a better move in this position F4 was
you know a very natural decision just
push the Pawns of course typical and by
the way at this point they were playing
on 20 seconds each F3 King to G3 this
was a mistake and at this point
last moment for Richie to potentially
keep a hold of this game with Rook to E1
instead of what he played Rook to E2
what is the difference the difference is
that if you do go Rook to F7
now I can give you a check and if you go
to F3 I can go E3 and now I control the
first rank Rook takes F3 E2 Rook to E3
and now I have E1 and my root control is
the first round so on the second rank
you cannot do this and also the Rook is
hanging right after yes so for example
if you try to go E3 Rook takes F3 you
can go with two you cannot take yes
and such my new detail that changes the
whole outcome of this game and after
that Magnus did not let him back into
the game wow very nice conversion by the
former world champion great great game
actually is full of fights and I was
checking the other game let's find it
Gary was playing an issue I think he's
inspired by maybe watching the movie
yesterday in the cinema I don't know I
heard that they went to check it with
Lucian gustos and his second so I mean
it was normal opening and then they got
this position with isolated Pawn which
is like Yasser told me that you should
know how to play with both colors in
this kind of positions so I think Gary
really played it well I mean he took
here for example with the pawn
yes and then and then okay
and then um let's say in this situation
uh he just stabilized everything the
Knight is on before you know and he just
kept playing this position it's nice
that he also found this move like Queen
C7 Rook d8 so now let's say all this
kind of Knight F6 are not working
because Queen G3 always comes so then
Knight C2 you know was a nice move and
this Knight started to move to the other
side of the board look at this 94 94 95
he played all these moves and I mean the
position was actually well fine but also
he decided not to exchange quiz because
after the exchange it would be just
equal position he saw it shows that he
kept fighting but here was a really
really interesting moment I will show
you I will go there so instead of Kim
jutung why it had this great opportunity
to take Bishop B6 and it looks
absolutely crazy like why do you give
this bishop and he has Queen D7 and it's
just positional I mean how to defend
after that like you're actually the one
getting checkmated yeah we need three
maybe yes immediately Queenie it exactly
so like Queen F2 you cannot play so then
Queenie eight and div King H7 then I
don't know many many checks are Maybe
foreign
looks really nice he missed it yes and
he missed it completely and after this I
think it was a critical moment because
Anish is very strong with his King and
sorry with his Queen and Knight right so
what happened is he simply went inside
of the Soul we would say we went
completely to the king's side and now
this queen became very annoying you know
he gives all these checks he just goes
here there creates lots of stress of
course and threads as well so we can see
like what was happening and he tricked
were Radical at certain point you know
so he here he exchanged one of the piece
and simply step by step he was just you
know going around and slowly slowly and
this night this bishop doesn't do
anything you see on on visual C4 is
really useful useless at this moment so
I mean here is you can see it it's over
all the bones are just falling and this
is how Anish one I think was really
quite you know aggressive play from
Anish who really tried to fight at any
moment of this game but Bishop B6 was
civilian great opportunity for other and
he understood well he's definitely
having a good time up to this point in
day one of Blitz Anish that is but
Anastasio actually caught up with some
fans outside so we're going to go on a
short commercial break but before that
we're going to see a feature of yourself
and some fans okay
we are here in Warsaw with mikoi who is
also a big chess fan he came today for
rabbit and Blitz super bet tournament so
how are you doing here do you like to be
here uh yeah I do so far I got the
signature from Wesley saw and now I'm
waiting for the second round to finish
to hopefully get some more yeah that's
cool have you been to the plane venue
and yeah I have but now I'm waiting here
because the players came here to talk to
the runs yeah yeah you need to catch the
players right now yes so who am I hoping
to catch today
I'm hoping to catch I know youngsters
wow big plans yes I mean are you a chess
player yourself
yeah but I'm not a professional player
just casual playing yeah so uh why did
why did you decide to come here
[Music]
because I live in Warsaw and it's very
unique opportunity to meet the best
players
hello Julian it's really nice to meet
you here during this Championship can
you tell us your impressions how is it
going for you
um it's going good I'm I'm happy that
photosho can do that has like good forum
and then managed to win with with great
setup players and it's also nice that
you know there's this event in Warsaw
where we can see the best players in the
world and this is really good for chess
I think yeah have you been to the plane
Hall not yet only only here yes really
what are you doing here then I'm playing
Just tournament that is now like next to
the main tournament and we are playing
Blitz and it's also fun yeah how is it
going it's going okay first tournament
it was like Ninth Place now like first
win and we'll see what's what's later
yeah what are you looking for here
I am looking for some good memories with
food players maybe see them in the real
life and it would be a great experience
have you met anyone already no not yet
it's my first time it's the first time I
see and what they're looking for are you
looking for missing stuff Duda or Magnus
yeah I mean Magnus Magnus would be fun
but also Wesley so or like Rapport
they're all great players yeah that's
for sure thank you so much and all the
best of luck in the tournament yes thank
you foreign
[Music]
welcome back everyone nothing like the
passion of Chess fans as we take a look
at our standings after six rounds of
Blitz now see what do you have for us we
have two co-leaders livon aronian and
young Kristoff Tuda and in the clear
third Wesley saw and Sharon fourth
Magnus Carlson and mvl creeping up is
Magnus Carlson now only one and a half
points out of the lead and tell us about
the pairings coming up for round seven
leave the table for us uh we have
Rockport planchevchenko giri against
Carlson it's tough because there's so
many great games let's go with Gary and
Magnus we haven't seen much of Magnus uh
Iranian against Roy tashek
one may be looking to
[Music]
do that against similar story there and
nvl against Wesley oh my gosh we've got
so many good backup plans that's got to
be Plan B uh the mvl as there's the
handshakes away we go and we are with
Anish and Magnus Carlson sicilium right
and
I've got to tell you Anish could be
winning all of his games it feels like
uh VAR he certainly had the positions
absolutely he could have had five and a
half out of six and with that two points
added to his score uh he would have been
getting closer to the leaders but there
were some missed opportunities for him
and uh but now Magnus again trying
something you know unusual trying to
just get a position where there wouldn't
be any Force Theory so he can get some
chances and he's trying to make Anish
think and we know Anish is a very strong
theoretician and just try to get a
playable position for Magnus to to have
some chances because he's still trailing
so he needs to get a couple more wins
playable position but help me out here
in Nancy you put your Bishop on D6
exactly why
[Laughter]
questions what's the bishop doing on D6
help me I think only magnets can answer
that because I have no idea plus it was
right after he played E5 he won Bishop
D6 so no explanation for that move well
you know I hear what you're saying VAR
that you're you're going off the Beaten
Track you're off reservation let's put
it that way but Bishop D6 really looks
confusing by the way once I see the move
castles I'm really really strongly
inclined to play Bishop G5 Knight C3 why
did I play A4 I thought the Knight was
going to go to A3 so I could go to C4
and immediately H6 just stopping Bishop
G5 H3 Prelude to F4 Knight going I don't
know white has so many options uh we are
out of book where did we go wrong when
did the novelty occur VAR yes we'll
check on the novelty and just the one
idea you were asking about the bishop so
that's exactly why he played the move
rookie Yasser he wants to go Bishop back
to f8 okay and then finally played the
move D6 and get that Bishop only six to
just get a normal position here okay 56
was just a temporary move to confuse a
niche that was the idea confused us I
don't know if it confused our Niche but
definitely our commentators were tasered
after that one so the new movie is H3
guys HD by white was the new move in
that position Bishop B3 and Knight H
were were played once only we're the
standard okay c2c3 tell us about the
current position bar just looks okay if
you had told me this came from a um what
do you say uh Joco piano I could imagine
the night going and playing C5 uh for
the moment uh I don't see any real
problems for black yeah absolutely black
is fine here and he needs to take on D5
here eliminate the strong Knight and
after Bishop takes D5 play the move
Bishop E6 similar thing different move
order he played Bishop E6 immediately
yes and here white has a few different
options here you can play the move
Bishop D2 or you can even play the move
C4 the C4 will simply cement the bishop
on D5 and at some point he will be
looking for an idea like Bishop D2 Rook
B1 B4 to try to get some Contra play on
a queen side but in that in that case
black actually has the move A5 here just
to try to completely blockade this
position and here white needs to find
some ideas to try to play with the F4
here black is very solid here but a very
very slight Advantage for y because of
this strong Bishop on D5 the current
position is with the bishop on E6 here I
would be very tempted as white to play
Knight takes F6 Queen takes F6 Knight H2
too idea to play Knight to G4 inviting
Bishop takes C4 I'm not really afraid
let black play his B5 with my Rook on A1
again if I was in on his shoes Knight
takes F6 Knight H2 and Knight G4 would
be my Approach b2b4 was a niche yes I
was going to say why it could also start
with Knight H2 not show yet that his
plan is Knight F6 okay but he went with
a very different plan before yes he did
here as black I might be tempted to take
and play Knight E7 just kind of shutting
down the
Outpost or maybe going B5 what indeed
that's what his last bit
B5 yeah I was gonna say B5 invites
Knight F6 and The Rook might land on A6
after a whole series of Trades whereas
in this position
um B5 is a big threat and I think I have
to play B5 myself could play A5 as well
A5
okay if black plays B5 then oh there we
go
from your words
here's A5
um Knight takes D5 obviously thank you
very much for taking my Pawn that work
walks into Queen B3 no Knight takes D5
but now Knight takes D5 might be on the
agenda Queen B3 defends the pawn
uh these double pawns make a strange
impression on me VAR I I like the two
Bishops but I'm not
overly happy with White's position
actually a very very big Advantage for
white here no kidding yes the two
Bishops are very strong and here uh you
can even you can even give up the pawn
here play the move Bishop E3 for example
Bishop E3 and before because if you take
on D5 with the neither is the move
Bishop C4 and then you're going to be
dropping the pawn on F7 here okay so big
moment here uh I like Bishop E3 because
I thought Rook C5 has a potential for
for for to be disruptive Rook to B1
showing that he's not afraid of Knight
takes D5 Bishop C4 what you mentioned
but maybe that Bishop E3 move was uh
nasty relaxed position is so passive
here it's hard to find most for Magnus
the move I wanted to play was Rook C5
and then if Bishop B3 what would you do
uh maybe the mother of necessity would
be to take and to take right or there is
Bishop B6 in that case after Bishop E3
um but I got to do something and what
are the clock times they play quickly
they both have about two minutes
I wish maybe we should play Knight F5 to
not allow Bishop
and there he goes once again uh well
done
looks like the only move yes yeah and
somehow the bishop on on uh B5 I I need
to put pressure I would like to Lead
With The Rook I often say that the queen
is most the best supporting actress
right you do you often times
yeah behind yeah
G4 okay take the Knight right back and
Knight went back to E7 Bishop C4 okay
defending the pawn VAR that move G4 very
double edged both both players happy or
who's happiest uh G4 was it's okay here
but I think now with this F4 Square
black is going to try to get some Contra
play with Knight G6 if we go back one
move in this position
uh G4 Knight E7 there was another option
here to play the move d4 immediately try
to open up the E file for The Rook okay
and the point is now if you play the
move E4 now white has this move G5 now
attacking the Knight on F6 all right and
if you move the Knight and Rook takes C4
and if you capture then Knight takes G5
with the idea to capture the Palm back
94 and here white would have had a
pretty big Advantage gotcha so after G4
he should have maybe followed it up with
D4 he did Play Bishop C4 Knight G6 as
you prescribed looking for counter play
uh with Knight F4 Queen B6 inviting a
queen trade what did he do should have
traded Queens because of the A6 A6 he
does have a knight D7 prepared oh that's
the nice move kicking out the queen just
in time I'm still uncomfortable with
Bishop A5 ideas so what if I just move
my queen away let's take
uh also I just heard that Dario said on
A6 black also has Queen C8 simple well
we're about to find out which what is
going to be simply Queen C8 or Knight D7
and here's what you were talking about
you were talking about the queen getting
kicked away but opening up the
possibility of Bishop A5 and Magnus
uh kind of taken aback by that move
Bishop A5 sacrifice actually but here if
you even give up the exchange with that
weak Square on F4 and the Knight will
simply land on F4 and I think black will
have a pretty good compensation even
down Exchange in some of these positions
yes
Bishop A5 and Knight F4 yeah five yeah
Knight A4 got it got it uh sorry we're
not cutting to your board bar because uh
it goes very quickly so the analysis
would go on my board and Bishop A5 takes
Knight F4 is the intuitive exchange
sacrifice and he's done it he's done it
and well here comes the exchange
sacrifice Bishop A5 Knight F4
C5
Knight C5
I like that move you defend the pawn on
A6 the Knight you are inviting D4 D4
very strong now for an ish immediately
without taking yes and because if
captured Knight equals Knight takes D4 a
lot will allow Knight C6 as well and
he's done I think Magnus missed this
move Knight C5 did invite D4 uh the more
I'm looking at it I would have liked to
have seen Knight F4 by Magnus and now if
White Knight comes to D4 it has this
amazing square on C6
the primary squares exactly you're
absolutely right right
and if the position wasn't intense
enough the clock times down to 20
seconds while Anish has 51 this is scary
for Magnus
and a niche is is playing dangerous
position and no time to think very very
well is putting the pressure and Magnus
is feeling it he's he's getting nervous
and he that nervousness is being
transferred you can feel uh five seconds
five
how much time did he have left when he
made that move one second one second
and now he's Bishop Queen Tech C7 came
immediately yeah okay put the Knight on
C6 but he's or since the epon is gone he
doesn't have that F4 Outpost for his
Knight anymore
yeah but I want the Knight C6 uh permits
me to play Rook to B8
right and once I can get my Rook on B8
you're in an eternal pin
by the way breaking news uh
Duda has won his game and chefchenko has
won his game against Robert and now we
have Rook B8 this looks oh no oh
dropping his pieces but Knight E6 Knight
E6
Knight F5
97. just went in right yes because you
got Queen F7
oh he's not he just took the pawn
black cannot get out of this pin
well he just did the queen D3
but
our Niche looking very very uncertain
because he has so many winning moves
that it's hard to choose from and now
it's a scramble it's a mad Scramble for
the clock the clock is deciding
everything
up maybe
crazy
yeah
what is he doing
oh my God once again Anish was
completely winning 97
let's just quickly jump to the Wesley so
game as mvl Wesley so huge game
um
uh winning because of the H Bond can I
go King H4 I see there's a table base
telling me to draw really yeah
because of Brook check and you can go
King yeah now it's a draw and this is
our last game all the others have been
exactly
and the players repeating we had one
draw levonne drew his game
you're saying four decisions yes
wow wow wow wow wow I think three
decisions three decisive games a three
um I'm still in a shock Magnus won
and just at the end there as they were
in time trouble we can just see some
fumbling of the pieces occurred right
four seconds and he hit the floor
and this clock is and he pressed his
clock with the piece prostrate on the
board
no
and Anisha is completely winning at this
point uh completely winning and he
played I think he had 1996 with the one
there on the spot in that position right
because
right yeah
wow what a turnaround what an amazing
turn bar what else have you what else
did you watch I was mesmerized by that
game I was mostly watching that game
with you guys but here Duda actually won
a very nice game here in this game he
defeated diac and a very important win
for him so let's take a look it's a very
messy position here Dak is doing fine
and he won two games in a row so uh and
here he had to just take on H6 for some
reason he didn't take the Knight a very
complicated messy position but he played
the move Knight H5 just picking up the
pawn and after the quiet move Queen F3
now this is just now completely losing
for black because your knight is hanging
and also the F7 Pawn so after this I
will show you how to do that very
quickly won the game Knight F4 played he
just took only five now the bishop is
gonna come in and as you can see black
Kink is in really really big trouble
here so Bishop takes E5 and now Bishop
F4 Bishop is hanging so he took on F4
and again if you take Queen H6 comes in
and after Knight F6 the blocking is
completely completely exposed here and
he simply won the game so one mistake by
diak and he basically got checkmated
another game actually uh chefchenko won
and I just want to show you the opening
part because Richie again played a very
uh unusual move in the opening he had
played this uh I think against in around
one he played the same opening but here
he he played this Rook lift but perhaps
this time it didn't work out very well
for him play this move Rook H4 right
here the idea is that if you go long
Castle he wants to play Rook C4 uh not a
bad idea but later on black managed to
get a really good position thanks to the
two Bishops and uh chefchenko won the
important game wonderful and let's just
take a look at the standings as again
the uh we're seeing a lot of flipping
going on all the time
as we have so after Judas win he's in
the clear lead again up by hop a point
and live on in the clear second and now
madness has jumped in the third place
creeping ever closer only one and a half
a points out of the lead but then Wesley
tying yeah sure in third place with
Magnus and npl in the fifth place
and more analysis from Warsaw
wow just an incredible round in Warsaw
and as I said what game were you
watching yeah I was watching the same
game as you you were checking the end of
the game between Wesley so and Maxima
shellegra I must tell it was really a
quiet game I mean between two really
great grand Masters Berlin very boring
stuff you know nothing was happening so
actually you showed the best of it like
it was the line probably both of the
players knew very well and they just
simply showed all these moves and were
extensional pieces until we got to this
fantastic Rook ending where still Maxi
was trying to push hard to to win but
Wesley defended like a tiger so nothing
else to tell what happened to you
I was watching this game between Levon
and voitashek and Levon as we've seen
he's in second place right now with a
win in this game which he did not get
they actually Drew this game but with
the win in this one he would have caught
up with Duda so a crucial game and he
had great chances I have to say I was
watching the game E4 C5 and by the way
everybody's inviting a fight nobody
definitely looking for a fight in this
one Knight D5 and we have a very typical
Sicilian we have white trying to expand
on the queen side A4 a5c4 at the right
moment and guess what black is going to
retaliate on the king side Knight moves
away from F6 F5 and try to push the pawn
um towards your click towards your king
try to Checkmate you basically this is
the plan it's very easy to understand
it's a bit more difficult to execute
yeah yes
it sounds good in theory right practice
is always a bit more difficult
E4 F4 and take a look at these points a
little bit dangerous yes that's the
thing it's such a such a difficult
position to assess forget about what the
computer is saying whenever you see this
type of Pawns coming your way it's not
easy to make the right decision there's
two humans right even you have to do
something with those phones exactly
exactly Knight to E6 take a look at this
F3 G takes F3 because that would open up
the king wow but Bishop takes F3 okay
very interesting move take on F3 Bishop
takes C5 your Bishop on G5
moves yes everything is hanging right so
it was an intermediate move yes F text
G2 so now you have to move the rook and
I like this idea don't take on G2 right
because if you take on G2 then the king
is going to be exposed exactly use this
Pawn on G2 as a shield for it's it's a
defensive mechanism for your king so
very nice move Rook to D1 take on G5 H6
Knight goes back to E6 I mean what a
beautiful Square on E6 right Rook F7
Queen G6 at this point it felt like
Levon was definitely on the verge of
winning this one yes yes but
unfortunately for him after Knight to E4
Rook to G4 was not the right move he was
supposed to take it in this instance
take on G2 Rook takes G2
Rook to G4 Knight to D6 Rook takes G2
but unfortunately right now this is not
the same iteration because the Knight is
on F5 yes Knight landed on F5 and from
there I can go to D4 I can go to H4
which is this is the big problem and I
still control D6 so now it seems
actually that voitage is maybe better in
this position Levon needs to pull the
brakes and try to make uh a draw but he
had a golden opportunity Knight to F3
huge blunder I can take on F3 with the
queen really exchange everything on F3
and then just simply B6 and the pawn
pushes you cannot stop it the game is
over wow he did not spot it he played
Queen to E3 and unfortunately that led
to simplifications massive
simplifications and just simply a
drawing this one it was nice game
actually it's a very nice game but I
have to say uh not one to beat that
clash between Magnus and Anish water
game that was just pieces flying all
over the place A Swindle but Magnus but
right now he's only one point and a half
behind yes everything is her head
everything to be played for in the last
couple of rounds here and of course
tomorrow still nine rounds to go back to
you guys thank you Anastasia and thank
you Christian it's window yeah we we
accept all kinds of things first of all
uh a tale of two players if you will
let's take a look at the line score of
Anish Gary and I mean look at that I
mean a roller coaster ride and guess
what he could have those losses
I mean it could be a picket fence of
Victories for him including the game he
just lost and the tale of another player
where you see on each Gary look at
what's going on with Magnus
the trifecta wins uh as he is really uh
established he'll say that he's finally
informed I think we can say that we are
entertained uh and uh through the magic
of Television we want to review a moment
right here we thought that Magnus may
have been
let's say unsupportive
because he while retreating he banged
the pawn on D6 kind of moved it off then
that fell over then his Queen and he
pressed his clock with his Queen
prostate on the board and that's not
fair but but I think it wasn't uh error
because he his hand was already going to
the clock when he knocked over the queen
okay so technically he didn't do
anything illegal
I don't know I don't know I don't know
unintentional let you be the judge of
that we we will we won't decide we're
going to take a break and we'll see on
the other side for round eight of the
blitz see you soon
[Music]
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States and
is among the best in the world thanks to
co-founders Dr Jeannie Karen singfield
and Rex sinkfield the St Louis chess
club is a non-profit organization
committed to promoting the game of chess
locally and internationally we bring the
educational benefits of Chess to
thousands of students across the St
Louis area promoting cognitive
development critical thinking
concentration and analytical skills the
St Louis chess club welcomed chess
lovers of any age and skill level to
come and enjoy the game of chess we also
promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sync field cup
Cairns cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over 2
000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back everybody to our live
coverage of the superbet rapid and Blitz
here are our standings after seven very
eventful rounds dude I still in the soul
lid and he has a half a point more than
levonne Iranian who is in the second
right and uh in Sharing third Magnus
Carlson and Wesley cell and then said
Wesley one and a half of points out of
first and Max and Michelle grab can
still catch up he's in the fifth place
just half Point behind Wesleyan Magnus
tell us about the upcoming airings for
round eight
we have chefchenko playing Wesley diach
against MPL
all Polish Game Boy tashek against Duda
that's gonna be our backup game and we
have of course Carlson against Iranian I
mean that's got to be the Marquee
match-up game right there report against
Gary wow uh lots and lots of decisive
games bar and each round seems to bring
out I don't know the best and worse of
the players absolutely a lot of wild
games at the game against Anish against
Magnus that could be a big difference
for Magnus here because if he can win
now he's he's right there and if he had
lost that game against Anish he would
have been you know languishing quite a
few points behind so but with that
victory that was a trifecta and he's
definitely got the momentum on his side
as he opens up holy smokes with the
center no the Danish gambits wow I mean
uh
Magnus has been all over the map in the
uh in his opening uh play what do you
think of his of his decision of our yes
I think I think it's his goal or
strategy in this tournament just trying
to surprise his opponent in every game
and play some offbeat lines he mentioned
that he hasn't been doing any chess
studying or practicing so he's
definitely a little bit drastic maybe
not us up to date on a current theory in
some of this critical lines so that's
why he's just trying to experiment in
the openings by the way I feel I too
have not up to date on the current
theory of this Ancient Ancient opening
and what does very Theory prescribe
Knight F3 or queen takes D4 he played
Knight F3 well also the move Knight F6
played by Levon it's not the most
popular move here Queen takes D5 is the
main move instead of Knight F6 right so
after Knight F6 we have uh we have only
a few games in the database here and
Knight F3 only one game actually so it's
a completely new territory here and 11
has the option to take back with the
Knight or with the queen and if you take
back with the queen we're gonna see
probably some isolated Pawn type of
positions C takes D5 that looks like
Scandinavian Bishop before check Knight
C3 and black and castle and we have this
isolated Palm position I think it's just
roughly equal at the moment but I tell
you this position with the isolated Pawn
after Queen takes D5 I mean if I'm white
I'm saying thank goodness I have that
position I don't have a Petrov I don't
have a Berlin it looks like a you know a
great game and but I think Lavon is
actually went into the tank right but he
recognize let's not forget Magnus did
sacrifice a pawn he's got it back on on
cue On Cue uh Knight takes D5 Queen
takes D4 okay uh Bishop B5 yeah seems
like a very standard approach here for
white by the way the queen on D4 is
annoying because the desirable Bishop to
E7 new bishop F6 will hang the G7 pawn
and we have Bishop I think that's still
playable
Queen E7 does white have Knight E5 now
because 95 is the best move
you don't have you don't have time for
F6 D5 seconds you know
you know I I agree with you 95 uh I was
just I mean it's gross uh forgive me but
I was I even thinking about one and Rook
don't do this at home everybody the king
D1 rookie one Bishop G5 uh but yes 95
what would happen after 95 are it's the
best move but it's also very unusual
idea you're checked and you're blocking
with the with the move and pinning
yourself but it's the best move here
Bishop D7
D7 uh that was force yes Bishop takes
66. I apologize
I'm assuming Bishop takes C6 and then
in both cases white just Castle soon is
actually much better much better much
better yes BC is probably a little bit
better just giving a little bit more
support to the D5 Knight so if he takes
BC just castles F6 you need to remove
this knight from E5 and let me eat that
Bishop yeah you take the bishop on D7
Queen takes D7 and now white will play
them move Rook D1 by the way we do have
Bishop take C6 on the board by Lavon and
castles is on the board Queen E6 by
Levon yes he's trying to perhaps capture
back with the queen but actually that's
not gonna work because the best move
here is Knight takes C6 which has been
which has happened and if you take with
the queen
rookie one check can we take one she
said you have to play Bishop G7 and in
this case you have actually two options
both moves are very strong here Queen G7
or I think I like this move even better
C4 removing the knight from D5 and we
have it on the board now the question I
mean I'm a pawn Grabber but I love that
move C4 as well because that move C4
means the king is stuck there's one
problem with Queen G7 long castle and
Rook G8 attacking G2 I'm taking your
pawns you're giving them to me G7 Queen
F7 it's a blitz and playing for
Checkmate is very easy
winning win your two pawns ahead is
really easy
I don't know actually I guess
after C4 guys I think you might like
this line so if you play C4 here yes
Knight B4 I think it's the most logical
try to create some threads you actually
ignore the fact that Knight C2 is coming
you just play Knight C3 developing so
Knight C2 Knight C2 take on E7 take on
E7 check with the Knight and now you
give up the other Rook as well Queen
takes G7 oh you don't even check with
the Knight you just lead with yes
because if you take on A1 now yep
Knight D5 check yep
and you don't want to lose the Rook yes
if you play King D7 or King E6 it's the
same thing I have Queen F6 so let's say
King D7 just Queen takes F7
Bishop G5 and as you can see the move 97
Wednesday Agnes is still thinking it
might just be calculating all this well
he's tempted by the pawn as we are and
then he's seeing C4 and he knows that
once he plays C4 and the Knight goes
that black king is stuck and he's
sensing opportunity here and this move
C4 right here right now key moment and
lastly is he gonna play C4 or queen G7
your intuition telling you I think he's
going to play C4 too but if he takes the
pawn on G7 we're going to send him a
gold membership and the coveted gold
membership to the pond grubbers
Association as president I'll have the
power
now well down to one minute and 35
seconds I mean he's investing a lot of
time in C4 and Lavon knows that C4 but
Levon saying take your time Magnus take
your time and he's done it G7 he's taken
quickly Castle Queen G4 check and he's
saying okay
gold gold membership for Magnus in the
and I just heard from Darius that queen
of three was a mistake
queen of three was a mistake it looks so
natural
Knight D2
and he's eyeballing just look I'm a pawn
up centralize my pieces get them
developed 94 Bishop g5s on my agenda VAR
I don't see the compensation here is
there
it's it's a little bit of compensation
here but that move Rook D6 would have
been definitely stronger with ideas I'm
so sorry to interrupt but I think Lavon
just wondered Bishop G5 is coming after
the queen trade you're right Knight B3
give me the bishop and Bishop G5 and
that's that's lights out a very strange
decision also to trade Queens because
that's the last thing you probably want
to do when you're just down a down a
pond here especially with the open G
file uh White's King was a little
vulnerable that's it that looks yeah
this is just completely lost the line
I'm looking at Bishop B6 Bishop G5 456
and just C4
oh and C5 you can't move the C Pawn with
black because Bishop F4 yeah that's
nasty as C5 and he's fighting Bishop B6
but Bishop G5 very com no
how could you not play Bishop G5 that's
an automatic was he afraid of Knight G4
maybe I missed something I don't know
Bishop G5 Knight G4 there's a bishop F2
check maybe in any case he played Bishop
E3 rather quickly what is the clock
situation does he one minute 25 seconds
for Magnus and about the same for Lavon
but this extra Pawn is fine and this
position is still much better but maybe
bishop G5 Knight G4 dissuaded him in any
case Bishop E3 don't tell me that he's
got compensation here for her because I
the in the immortal words of bent Larson
nobody will believe you no he does not
have a compensation it's just a plus
three plus three it's just completely
winning okay Rook E8 on the board Bishop
takes and Knight D4 we caught up with
players and yeah not only is it an extra
Pawn by the way it's the weaknesses too
so Queen F6 by Levon was a huge blunder
it was it was it was just that's just
that's it it was a huge plunger 94
and G3 just very very nicely
consolidating
and there's nothing you can really
attack that's the problem for Lavon
there is no Contra play something that
you can attack to confuse your opponent
or create some chances exactly he's
doing his best
eyeballing an opportunity in the near
future playing Knight C4 trying to
create something but King G2
Knight C4 B3 get out of here nobody
cares King G2
C5 okay throw it out there why not
and Knight F3
and Trey trade what do we do when we're
ahead everybody exchange exchange pieces
that's been a winning formula you won't
believe it for 16. now Knight G5 is a
threat here Knight G5 attacking H7 and
also setting up Knight X F7 with rookie
seven idea that's Cameron white has an
extra Pawn black has doubled pawns and
separated pawns on the king side right
this is a very easy this could be a huge
win for Magnus should be but it's it's
about the clocks now as well as nerves I
mean you know everybody knows when
you're winning but you know just
bringing the point home that's that's
the tough part
one minute
and Rook drop back to E2 interesting
move I thought that Magnus might have
been contemplating Rook E5 maybe he
doesn't want to give liberal Knight C4
Knight B2 yeah any counter chances
whatsoever but uh I thought he was going
for that uh instead he dropped back with
the rook and it's time for this Knight
to come into the game love that he heard
you yeah love that move and oh
Lavon immediately as he was releasing
his King walked into Knight takes
resignation very soon that's a second
pawn and oh
I think H6 is also lost with the yeah
there we go yeah oh and by the way
Magnus Carlson four in a row I think as
we were coming into the into the studio
today you were saying that's what Magnus
needs that's what Magnus got let's jump
to The Duda game
do the present uh with the black pieces
board three yes goddess love
yeah that's one of these ex benoni
exchange sacrifices where the dominant
dark squared Bishop even though his key
factor down in exchange his Bishop on E5
is better than any Rook correct on this
board exactly in in White's King
in some danger for sure I'm thinking I'm
ready to give an exchange back here with
the move work F5 I mean but I do
recognize that that is a painful
decision because it's the exchange that
is what white is playing for but Rook F5
Bishop F5 Rook F5
oh pardon me he took the pawn which is a
surprise move
so you just want to block the pawn
either with F6 or queen F6 and now this
bishop no I'm not I'm not a fan of what
uh radislav just did it's a known thing
that when there's opposite color Bishops
the player who is attacking yes is
better and here White's King is
absolutely terrible Bishop on E5 is such
a strong piece I couldn't agree with you
more that's exactly the situation
because when you have the initiative
with Bishops of opposite color you are
attacking on a complex of squares in
this case the dark swears they can't be
defended it's really that simple
and uh players under 10 seconds so you
know anything can happen still well
we're about to see a king walk as
Black's King is going to make a beeline
to the queen side uh where it will be
safer for example on the A6 square and
then
and I think dude is playing brilliant
game thus far can he keep it up far
what do you think about this move Rook
E3 I love it I think he's completely
winning here and it's very well now okay
winning the Queen the big blunder five
he takes F5 was a big blunder
and let's just jump to the game of Dia
and I see one more result Richard has
one
once go to
dioc against them via
the very top and we saw a resignation
NBA
wow uh Daniel is uh
and Wesley Drew here
Daniel's playing a bit of a role of a
spoiler here I mean he he's in his time
trouble but he plays very well with no
time on his clock VAR uh take it away
tell us what caught your eye in this
round eight yeah two games caught my eye
first I want to show you this moment
here and do that game do that winning
which is very very big win for him he's
you know staying in the lead and now
here The Rook F5 move it's very
uncomfortable position already for white
because your Bishop on C2 is very
passive so he made I think the right
decision to sacrifice The Exchange but
when uh black took on F5 he had to take
back with the Rook here and I will show
you difference here so Rook takes F5 I
think is the practically practical good
decision here and you have to take back
with the Rook here because now after
Pawn takes you just after Queen F6 it's
just a really difficult position to play
you have no Contra play with the Rook on
F5 you will have some Contra play you
have some cringy Queen G5 idea for
example exchanging Queens then you
you're absolutely fine here
so in fact black needs to play this move
F6 to prevent that and now you can bring
your Bishop into the game Bishop D1 and
here black is only very slightly better
here Bishop D4 Queen F4 and I think with
Usher definitely would have had some
chances here to hold this position the
other game that caught my eye was uh
they are actually getting a really big
Advantage out of the opening here there
was a surprising move uh I saw by mvl
here so in this position when he'll
and right right around here the move
Queen D7 I was a little bit surprised
because you oftentimes want this Square
for your knight on D7 and the Queen on
D7 is not very well placed because
you're gonna run into the move E5 and
that's exactly what happened he played
them with Queen D7 Rook fd1
rook fc8 and E5 after this it's actually
a very big Advantage for white removing
the knight from F6 and you went back 98
and captures and C5 and I also have the
queen side majority and the Knight
actually landed on D5 and it was a very
big Advantage for deck and he eventually
converted into a very nice win against
MBL very impressive indeed and let's
take a look at our standings after uh
round eight we only have one more to
play today right dude that increase his
leading tournament by that win so young
Crystal and solid
Italian per second however Magnus
Carlson and livon aronian and you can
see what Magnus has been doing with the
blitz line as he has scored six out of
seven wow very very impressive
and for more analysis from Warsaw
[Music]
foreign
a couple of very interesting games and
one that I want to focus on is the one
between hiru chefchenko and a player
that needs victories in this tournament
if he wants to stay within contention
and that is Wesley so with the black
pieces and let's take a look at what
happened in this one Bishop to B5 and
another patented Knight to F6 the Berlin
that we see from Wesley so many times
but in fact he's showing that he wants
to win so that's why he played this move
A6 Bishop to A4 Knight to F6 Knight to
C3 Bishop to C5
Bishop takes C6 B takes C6 I do believe
that we have some technical difficulties
with our screen so unfortunately we
won't be able to show you this game but
Anastasia you also tell us a bit about
the game that you were watching yes it
was it's really hard to show it without
the code
giving my emotions yes it was a really
crazy game I mean it's it the scenario
was very similar to the game uh when and
well played against Anish giri uh some
rounds ago you know so gear was
absolutely been completely winning like
a computer was showing plus six at minus
six because he played with black at
certain point and then everything went
absolutely crazy and then Richard took
over and he won this game I mean
Elizabeth if you miss this game you
should definitely check it out because
it's you will have a lot of fun so one
is missed against Richie against Magnus
yes it's like he gets really great
positions and he plays so creatively so
energetically but at certain point when
you really need just you know we finish
your opponent at this moment something
happens to him I don't know really
what's going on but we will ask him
after everything and he did win some
games as well so he's definitely not
doing bad today compared to the previous
days we know that Anish has had a rough
event so far but still missing some of
his chances now let's take a look look
at the leader Duda and his score line in
this event because he entered this uh
today's rounds with a three-point lead
over Magnus now he only has a one and a
half point lead over Magnus but still
one half pointed that's quite a lot take
a look lost a couple but one three of
them so he's still on a plus one result
very very good result for the young
polish Superstar and let's take a look
at the full standings let's check the
stand access and remember is leading at
the moment as you said Christian and
then Magnus shares the second place
together with Livonia both of them they
have 16s and then Wesley saw 15 and a
half as you said he really needs to win
couple of games Maxime is full and with
14 and half and so on
um and I have to tell you Wesley was
actually winning in that game
unfortunately we won't be able to show
it but he was winning he missed some
opportunities unfortunately for him just
a draw but uh still lots of games and
lots of Chess to be played in this event
yeah but we have last round to the years
last round today yes coming up and we're
going to go on a short commercial break
we'll be back shortly don't go anywhere
you don't want to miss this
all right
the beauty in Forest Park
it's your move the muni premiere of
Chess plays the muni through July 11th
sponsored by St Louis chess club and the
World Chess Hall of Fame for
ticketsmuni.org
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why Jess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
hello and welcome back so far the blitz
have been stunning games uh leaving us
kind of breathless actually what are our
standings after eight rounds yeah
Christoph dude are still in the clear
first but how impressive that out of
seven rounds Magnus Carlson scored six
points today a hat tip absolutely now
he's sharing second with Livonia exactly
and those guys are the most likely to
win the event as uh they're really kind
of gapping away a little bit uh tell us
about the pairings for the ninth and
final round of today
right we have kirichevchenko Iranian
wrapper and the biggest match up dude
against Carlson yeah you don't see how
you how you don't pick number one and
number two in the competition uh nvl
against Roy tashak and so against theek
we'll keep Lavon and Richie as a backup
but the game between Duda and Carlson
that's going to decide uh who's well
actually due to even loses yeah he still
think he's got a clear lid yeah he's got
a clear lead going into our final day of
competition and who said that someone's
going to be in clearly going into
tomorrow I said there was going to be a
a tie
and Duda has surprised me by saving some
positions that maybe he should have lost
and winning some positions that maybe he
should have drawn so a hat tip to do to
avar absolutely yeah he's playing really
well in the last few rounds but again
Magnus is four in a row now four wins
for him and this is a huge game if
Magnus can win this I think he will have
an excellent chance to win but if Duda
wins in I think the Gap will be two and
a half points from Magnus so
um you know this this game could mean a
lot for the tournament uh the games that
Magnus have lost in Nasi I feel like
their self-inflicted wounds he's played
the Polish defense he's he's done some
secondary stuff right I think he started
the clock a bit prematurely or I think
he he pressed the wrong button actually
so I mean what I'm saying is he's taken
excessive wrists as black yes
that was very impressive but again he
came back recovered very quickly after
that loss and won four games in a row
yes yes
uh we I think of the trifecta I've got
that part but or the hat trick if you
will why winning three games what do
they call it winning four games in a row
I think in soccer they call it the poker
or something poker poker a poker yeah
but I could be there might be something
else so very interesting opening Choice
here inviting a kind of a banana benoni
yeah
so expecting Knight F6 and
potentially A5 here world championship
match actually Dubai right
nepo and Magnus were exploring some Max
this one with block yeah
uh exploring some of these lines VAR
Bishop C5
reinforcing the pawn on D4 simply
developing and asking why are you
playing for A3 you're going to go Knight
A3 you're going to go Knight D2 to E4
what should what you gonna do I think
there's
one of the things about a world
championship match and training for
those matches I mean it's sort of like
you stock up
Weaponry open openings because it's so
rare that you even show five percent of
what you prepared so you really carry
for I want to say a number of months and
even potentially years Magnus Carlson
played five World Championship matches
he's so very very well prepared he knows
his openings so very well Knight D2
point out that we're following this game
Iranian do that where Duda was with the
black pieces yes position
uh just last year that that is to say uh
the theory yes a queen d8 I would have
expected the queen to be on E7 but he
chose d8 potentially to meet Knight E4 I
suppose with Bishop to E7
um right now I'm not feeling it for
white I like the two Bishops I like the
space uh what do the engines say about
this position VAR engine thinks the
position is about equal here but I also
like this for black uh uh what white
really wants to do in this position is
to try to prepare a3b4 yeah this is the
idea that was suggested by the engine
but the move F4 wow
[Music]
please could you explain that now the
correct answer is I told you not to ask
me that that's from Get Smart
get Smart one of my favorite shows as a
kid
Agent 99 and now guys Bishop C6 is the
next move that is just actually
suggested as the best option I guess
people didn't want Magnus to play E5
that's the explanation for a full rate
I came up with another there you go uh
by the way Bishop takes C6 is a
definitely look at them they're bent
Larson games as well as off Anderson
games where you would play Bishop takes
C6 and that specific position uh giving
up the two Bishops uh for the two nights
because the knights do have squares by
the way Bishop D7 developing move but I
think also
saying please I don't want to give you
the opportunity of playing
um
uh Bishop takes E6 now the question is
should I be playing for B4 a b Knight B3
and looking to play Knight to B5 Magnus
says
I don't know what you're doing I'm gonna
shut you down I'm not gonna let you play
um for that and by the way Bishop C6 is
on Black's agenda I'm still liking the
position for black variety
Advantage for black yes black is better
here and one idea which is The Rook B8
is suggested by engines to try to play
the move B5 to open up the B file and
put pressure on the B Dupont this is a
typical idea we see sometimes in a bit
only positions and after move Rook B8
the best move for white would be to try
to play Rook AP1 just to make sure he is
ready when the B5 move comes in and the
B2 Pawn is not hanging uh
when you play the move B5 you are a
little bit weakening the C6 Square so
there is a possibility of a move Knight
B4 and now there is a threat of also
Knight A6 forking the bishop and Rook
but in this case now you will play the
smooth Queen C8 to eliminate that and
also not to be under
um idea like Knight C6 attacking the
queen here so here now engine is just
shifting here now starting to play with
the move G4 but uh it's it's very hard
to play like this but Black is Black is
slightly better here Bishop E7 one guess
what move Magnum no I would not have
guessed Bishop D7 to C8 not at all
Bishop to C8
wow
um okay explain that one never mind the
others that I can't explain that one
because Magnus already made the next
couple moves oh you want to play Rook A6
and bring the Rook
into the game from that side
um
very original any good Grandmaster would
see it right away uh gee uh vard this is
a
you know the players are not
appreciating the commentators here
running is into submission uh can't
guess these last few moves I must say
I'm I I'm mystified yes but I think this
is good for black now next thing he
wants to do is put a knight on B3 okay
and play the move C5 okay removing the
Knight back to C2 and then he can put
the bishop on B8 and start preparing the
idea like F5 E5 and that Rook could be
very well placed on B6 you can bring it
over to F6 G6 you'll have many options I
I like this Rook on B6 actually
P6 so creative it is if I play Knight C5
right here night right now like give me
the pawn on A4 now Rook D6
and if I take the pawn
take the pawn on A4 C5 oh I see and my
knight might actually end up Knight A2
first I go Knight B3 my knight might be
getting uh and then after Bishop D7 the
Knight on A4 is trapped fantastic wow
that's what happens when you get your
hand caught in the cookie jar folks I'm
just going to refresh my uh board don't
uh Don't Panic
um some time ago there was a suggestion
maybe of G4 oh we do you have Knight C5
okay here we go Rook D6 is the key move
and he's done it just repeat and play
94. the idea black will go to D7 now
nice I love it because you want to play
C5 now that's why and and then also the
Knight on e4 could be kicked with F5 at
some point as well so this is nice five
C5 kick the knights out plant your night
on B3 and life is good Rook uh is our
clock tutor is under one minute
and two and a half for Magnus now Duda
has like dioc been playing perpetually
under the pressure of the ticking clock
and not getting
punished for it uh but I I think it's
too much to ask no by the way the move
C5 inviting F5
why didn't he play F5
not sure but he allowed C6 which might
be
quite good for white
but wow just a moment ago wasn't there
pesky their F5
F5 uh perhaps a possibility but after
the move C5 he could have just played C6
also first blockading that pawn and then
getting ready to play the move F5 right
so do you get Advantage for Block if he
had done C6 okay did not happen he
played Knight B3 allowing C and the
positions a bit of a mess but
still I gotta say I I'm still liking the
two Bishops
me too but that pawn on C6 got in there
and like yeah it is a a bone in the
throat right yeah Queen D6 Bishop C5 but
I'm playing for E5 where is whites break
so again I want to play Queen D6 I want
to play Bishop C5 and I want to play E5
and if I'm Magnus I'm feeling I'm
playing for two results
it looks that way we're up to B1 dude is
not looking very happy no Bishop C5
simply E5
and Magnus
no now he's going to start playing on
the king side and black people liking it
I'm liking it
Wesley won his game against the arc
important to keep the pressure because
he was in the fourth place coming into
this round right on the on the
tournament leaders can keep the pressure
three
wow no I I I really do like it for
Magnus and I was also looking at even
the move F of five F4 just reminding
white king is a little bit exposed your
pieces on the queen side or let's say
distant he's playing
like
well if he wants to he
G5 or F4 I'm I'm feeling it on the king
side and I love this move f
5 F4 and G5 as you said just gaining
some space and this move F4 is still
looking like a really really great move
I I mean
F4 bar
Zack actually the evaluation dropped and
looks like now Duda is getting some
controverty because the B5 Pawn is
hanging and this this whole idea with G5
G4 maybe was just a little bit too slow
here he could have just played the move
F4 immediately right if you play the
move F4 now just G takes F4 and if I go
Rook F5
so I'm looking forward
Rook uh Rook takes B5 Rook takes F4 I
was hoping that I was going to go Splat
on the king side Queen H4 activating the
queen H4
and magnus's clock is ticking away right
yeah it's very unclear now the position
wow I'm just going to refresh my board
everybody do not panic
where am I where am I and we just so
quickly MBL also won his game we do have
f4 on the board GF Rook H five not Rook
F5 yeah they do say that Checkmate ends
the game is the goal but what
he's done it Rook takes F4 this was
magnus's and the sacrifice of the queen
for the two Rooks we've seen this
material imbalance throughout
bad throughout the tournament but wait a
minute
can I take Rook B5 first rugby five
and there's a check on B1 and Magnus
spotted it
oh but just Rook F1
yeah because we just exchanged the Rooks
in a very strange way but uh the good
news for magnus's fans is this night
is bad but it does have an extra Pawn
well there it goes if he did I I didn't
make I didn't make the count
Bishops of Papa's color Bishop
but is black still bearable
it's it's equal at the moment I think
white will have some country play with
that a file Bishop A5 that was a good
move the frustrated uh Duda there you
saw due to kind of like smirking like
why did I ooh G3 why did I allow this
wait a minute Rook H2 check making moves
with one second on the clock well never
mind that but uh
he's losing he's losing you can't take
on H5
well not yet but if the king finally
comes back to the game like he did
I don't know this is looking really
really good for Magnus
well with this time control yes yes
and Magnus is saying H4 is gone so
Bishop check
oh
I mean definitely way easier to play
this with black pieces of course but if
it's actually winning I'm not sure not
sure either anymore
probably not
and if Tuda saves this again it's just
remarkable I mean he has more lives than
an alley cat I tell you I thought maybe
bishop D2 check just to kind of Kick the
king a little bit further away from
the pawn
oh
mine was at the pawn again so he has
chances to win again
I think do they just blundered that pawn
most likely but the The Rook on G5 is
not making a great impression uh oh it's
going to be one of those time scrambles
where the king comes to E3 so that you
could go Rook takes E4 check
it's it's feeling like it's winning yeah
King to D2 to E3 and maybe even Rook F4
rookie four was rookie four yes and then
D3 exactly technique to win equal end
games it's unparalleled King F1 King F1
anyone else who does that King F1 was
almost as zuk Swang I wanted to say
there's almost Checkmate also coming he
needs to sacrifice The Rook for that
Bishop that's the that's the key that's
the key key idea here and if I go G2
no he didn't want to go G2 I think just
Rook a two check it'll be just a lot of
checks on a first would be a lot of
checks okay
Fair
and you know what he wants to do he's
telegraphing his move of exchange
sacrifice
and same story Rook is coming to come to
E8
Rook is coming to E8 it's not
direct because every time he threatens
to take it to the moves his Bishop well
here it goes to take it now take the
bishop and do the shaking his head as
he's recognized he's he's in a losing
position D3 and Magnus rocks and rolls
the case where two pawns are better than
a rook
yeah and there it is Magnus doing what
he has to do five in a row now that
that's a very beautiful but amazing it's
it's amazing I have seen it throughout
his career he is an extraordinarily
gifted player I'm looking at this round
and we didn't have a single draw all
five decisive results
wow what can we say Blitz is great
but there was a couple of moments there
when dudo made moves with just a second
on his clock and hear through the magic
of Television is one of them
there's one and I think he did that
twice in a row
yeah and here it comes again because
Rook check and Bishop D2 on magnusogen
yeah like right froze like how did they
do that it's like it's a they have an
instinct bar how do you know when to
slap your clock with a mere second on it
yeah it's it's very tough it's tough and
uh we'll take a look at our standings
after the completion of our first day of
Blitz
yeah I'm still in the lid but only half
point I had Magnus Carlson wow
and then Half Point behind Wesley so and
while we didn't get to see that game but
the one lost his last game so he's in
the fourth place now okay and there you
can see who the buds expert Specialists
really are by the way had to to Carol
with five and a half points in the blitz
you know in this galaxy of stars that's
that's impressive as we prepare to wrap
it but the bar your uh
but nvl also still has chances there's
only half Point behind yeah because of
uh those standings as we get ready for
uh we're waiting to interview Magnus yes
who's sure he's in a very good mood
wow so he won five games in a row and
Wesley is not doing that but he's couple
of wins for him at the end he's he's in
a Striking Distance he's in the third
place right yeah one point behind to do
that nice
wow and even though Magnus lost got
outplayed against Wesley to start to
start with right and he comes back and
wins five games yeah and let's jump to
Warsaw uh with Magnus and Christian
Magnus you started the day three points
Behind The Duda now you're only half a
point behind do that and you're actually
surprised by that yeah I mean I didn't I
I made like a conscious effort not to
look at the standings all day partly
because it's I start to look at it when
you're when you're when you're doing
well but um yeah obviously now it's
anyone's going on you started off slowly
you lost the game but after that you
just started you won five in a row
basically what changed at that point
to be honest like I didn't feel so good
today uh I I mean I stayed up to to
watch the Miami Boston game yeah I mean
I was going to go to sleep but then the
game was
exciting and then but the problem was I
couldn't sleep so well earlier today so
yeah I didn't feel feel great and to be
honest like the amount of luck I had
a turning point actually yeah yeah
no it's just
for each of those five games to all
ending wins like so many things had to
go go right but I'll take it of course
of course and let's talk about uh this
last game because
you definitely came out with an
aggressive stance yeah okay but this was
yeah this was an insane movement like uh
why on Earth did I not go Knight A5
that's what I realized like right right
after because I was thinking that the
pawn was hanging but after you see 92 I
was thinking that I need to go Bishop D4
first uh Bishop D7 first down then uh
but anyway I mean so many things
happened and was the strategical point
behind the Knight A5 just yeah you just
want to climb down on the on the queen
side and then as long as white doesn't
have like Italian chances on
um on the king side you have a space
advantage and uh and a bishop area so
the long-term prospects are are pretty
pretty nice and you were out playing him
but then yeah a little bit wild yeah
uh wouldn't you feel like you're losing
uh oh no I was losing control here
because I mean I could tell
I could tell that my position was
probably winning uh but I had no idea
what to do
um and you had two minutes and he had
only 13 seconds so yeah uh but but here
like up to this point at least for a
while like all of my moves have been
completely automatic and now I actually
have to think and I failed
uh spectacular
all right let's see G5 G4S yeah like
ideas like rookie eight then Knight C2
Bishop D5 I didn't think about it at all
like just to hold okay yeah but here I I
knew that this F4 stuff was crazy but I
I just didn't I just didn't see what to
do at this point no at this point but
this whole plan yeah was was insane yeah
um you guys got to this end game yeah
I'm probably not probably not worse but
I'm not really better either oh for a
second you thought that you might even
be worse yeah like a little bit before
but now yeah
um
I mean basically we just got to this
kind of
um position and like once I get this H
Pawn with seconds I think I'm
considerably considerably more likely to
win than he is to
to make a draw because I can just move
around forever and it's really funny
that we're just playing on opposite
color complexes and nothing's really you
know vulnerable but eventually I I
figured I should be able to get to get
the king and get the yeah
Magnus congratulations huge day for you
yeah I should say one thing though
um so I did play the so
um first of all huge congratulations to
uh my good friend and Coach uh Peter uh
who has his 50th um birthday uh today
um so I asked him yesterday if he had
any wishes and His Wish was that I
played the Danish Gambit and that's what
I tried to do against Lavon
yeah so I'm sure he'll be
um be be happy about that and also he is
not here with you because of his fifth
year anniversary right
um yeah also like
he usually doesn't come to the
that's normal what are you going to do
tonight in preparation for tomorrow
to play some football with um
with a few player so
it could be fun that should be fun yeah
Magnus thank you very much we'll see you
tomorrow thank you guys
congratulations Peter Heine Nielsen long
time coach of Magnus Danish Gambit happy
birthday yeah birthday gift let's take
some line scores uh starting uh with the
player in third place Levon aronian
thank you for the fourth right now I
apologize for that he he had a
yes but very bad finish in the last game
he had a chance actually he could have
maybe won the game but made the blunder
and immediately lost the game so it was
a one point swing in the round number
nine against airport very unfortunate
for Lebon right who comes up next
uh Magnus in second uh position and
that's why so beautiful it does five
ones in a row it's like that pick a text
you know I twice won seven classical
games in a row it looks so nice on the
cross table but that's very impressive
five in the Blitz and uh how about our
first place leader our leader Duda also
big swings
three wins three losses uh and three
draws and remember he's the defending
Champion he last year when he won it he
didn't win the Rapids he won it through
the blitz he came in big time so he's
not going to be happy about his 50
percent in the blitz day one but day two
Blitz coming up tomorrow and I gotta say
uh I feel like the tournament's up for
grabs absolutely I think Matt Magnus is
back and uh the half a point lead with
nine games to go anything can happen and
they're gonna play each other in the
last round tomorrow yes do that the
colors will have white in that game and
it might be frozen
for him to win five games in a row so
many things had to go his way right
and let's jump uh to Warsaw as Christian
is with Wesley so
Wesley you were keeping contact with the
leaders all throughout this event and
you're definitely trying uh even
signaling not playing the Berlin playing
Asics trying to keep the game going
against kiril and you had some chances
in that one as well but you did finish
with an important Victory some your day
for us
pretty
Tata
you know I just take one day at a time
take chances whenever it appears and uh
just play hired me I'm kind of
regretting
going for such a complex variation
against any shakiri you know and the
white pieces there it was a good chance
but
but I got over ambitious and then he
punished me
for for that but I'm just trying to play
some
good chess you know if if possible
speaking of good just let's analyze this
game the final one against was having a
pretty decent event he was definitely
upsetting some people yeah I mean he had
very bad days and he's had some good
days like the first day he lost all
three rapid games yes and then after
that he recovered uh also here he won
two in a row at some point
so it's been a like when when he's in
good form he can play really well yeah
full respect to him but he's very well
prepared in the opening so that's why I
decided to you're trying to take him out
early on yeah go for this line yeah
because uh he's been well prepared in
one e45 openings he made an easy draw
against Magnus in the better off so it's
pretty well versed I'm a bit surprised
that he plays night after eater with
white when he's such a good tradition
but
kind of mix up his
uh opening real early I thought I
thought black should try to prevent
Bishop Dieter and E4 by like playing
Knight A5 here for that Bishop Leader by
Bishop E4 maybe bishop to E4 yeah yeah
that's the entire plan
so actually I played this against him
before back in 2019 in Gibraltar okay so
but then he makes up his move order and
after E4 he's taught for so E5 is
already a mistake well if I was a
blunder yes so then he what's the point
behind it because the CD4 looks
aggressive right yeah because now I get
the D5 I mean I think this is just
losing for black after I'm gonna play
Bishop F5 say sacrifice the pawn pick it
up later but you just have this amazing
attack yeah yep uh black always has to
be a bit careful because the Rook is on
the same
directly attacking the enemy Queen big
pin yes yeah if I started shaking his
head a lot and then he spent two and a
half minutes
but there was no way to uh prepare the
situation I was very happy when I fact
Knight takes E5 I guess maybe it's not
the best move but when you have two
Bishops and a few Pawns I think I think
Knight takes E5 is actually the best
from a practical perspective for sure
maybe even objectively yeah probably
because the Bishops are just too strong
they just want to grab a pawn as much as
possible but actually E5 wasn't mistaken
yes
seven
he could have defended uh better yes but
still the position even here remains
very difficult for him yeah but it's
been an interesting uh you know day for
me now I'm obviously very happy to beat
Magnus I'm assume you're gonna want to
have this Revenge very badly after that
but maybe you should thank me actually
because he got very motivated after he
got angry after he lost against you
that's true yeah yeah he had uh you know
bug dance tried to slow hit him down a
bit I believe right but then after that
he just got on on a roll yeah absolutely
well with one day to go you are one
point behind Duda have a point behind
um Magnus what do you need to do
tomorrow to win this event because I'm
sure these are your ambitions
well if I played like I did today I
think I
okay winning first place is not easy
because you got Magnus I I thought
Magnus will be in bad form after the
first couple days but I started to uh
pick up like I thought before this event
like maybe hasn't look at chess for an
entire month but apparently he has so I
feel very difficult to never safe to
come with him out yeah yeah if you win
if you score plus five on on Blitz on
one day
and then you score another good then
it's very difficult to stop you like
last year remember Fabiano had plus 10
is just
unimaginable to me how anyone can score
plus 10 on 18 games but I think if I
play like I did today uh you know just
try to avoid too many Planters and play
some good chess then maybe I'll have a a
chance uh
because I think other than my game
against Anish Geary my games today were
pretty okay definitely a good plan
Wesley and uh we'll let you go get some
rest and we'll see it tomorrow get some
sleep you know get some sleeping all
right
guys back to you in the studio thank you
Wesley and thank you Christian I mean
that's uh plus five there uh just to
remind everybody of our schedule
tomorrow is our last day right don't
forget to join us for the last day it's
going to be exciting nine more rounds of
Blitz and playoffs if necessary oh that
will be exciting
of the scenario might look like that
would require a tire of course and Vara
I am very eventful uh day one of Blitz
uh a lot of roller coaster rides for the
players what were your thoughts I'm
watching it unfold absolutely that's why
we like the blitz format and there were
a lot of chances for Levon unfortunately
he just at the very end he stumbled he
he if he didn't lose this last game
against Richie he would have been okay
but now he is falling a little bit
behind but Magnus five in a row and if
he continues plays this way I think he's
going to be able to just uh surpass dude
and win the tournament but Wesley is
also playing well so one point to only
behind the leader so I think he's got
his chances as well so I'm very excited
to see this nine police games tomorrow
right and thank you for that and let's
uh just go to final thoughts from Warsaw
Poland
well right now my heart is racing just
incredible games all throughout the day
swings Thrills and Spills but Anastasia
you actually lived that last final game
from inside the playing hole that game
between Duda and Magnus how would that
feel I was there yes one of the
spectators and it felt really really
tense you know the boss players were
fighting until the end and you could see
it on the boards but also after the game
was over like all emotions started to
come out and Magnus was so emotional
people were uploading he still put his
pieces back to the starting position he
has this habit you know no matter what
he always puts pieces back so it was
really really intense moment and I would
like to say to tell to our viewers that
we have all these small videos in our
social media accounts already published
so please come there Grant your store
follow us and you will see more and more
information from event well definitely
the script is not yet ready but it's
definitely going to be an exciting
finish so many possibilities so many
narratives and everything is going to be
concluded tomorrow guys
thank you Christian I just want to say
thank you for joining us sharing your
day uh it's all or nothing for tomorrow
everything to play for uh
all the players of course but absolutely
absolutely we'll see you all tomorrow
see you tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited